oh
wait how do you do how do you do that
yeah you wish you knew the powers of
mine i don't know
ah
where's my lid
of course i need that lid it's a
collection item
it needs the lipstick why'd you have a
mug with no liquid in it yeah
why are you asking for a little why are
you asking for a lid if you're not gonna
drink coffee
i do actually but also you know i think
of this mug as a collector's pieces
should the viewers who bought it and it
should always have the lid on it yeah
but there's yeah you don't have like
santa claus without the red suit on you
know what i mean like you don't have a
trash taste mug without the lid yeah but
you just got it on you you have like a
coffee cup right there and you have like
a mustache that's unused
there get this out of you why is there a
little on the floor did you drink the
coffee not out of the trash taste mug
i don't like transferring liquids from
like fake trash taste fan
i also want my trash taste like
transferring liquids
i i like i like the the mug what is this
man's mug look at this [ __ ]
how did you get the [ __ ] off you know
what i've been drinking out of it
this is just like drinking it
used you [ __ ] slobbered all over it
half the coffee's on the [ __ ] mud
have you seen this man drink yeah
he's like he's like he doesn't know
where his mouth is
gone is like a like somebody like a
person who used to be a dog in like
another life but just never forgot how
to like
he drinks like his mouth are you kidding
me i would love to be a dog in my next
life or this car in life dogs have like
the easiest [ __ ] lives in existence
dogs and cats you just you just do
nothing all day they piss [ __ ] and
unconditionally love that's all they do
right
that's what the dog is i watched i
watched
have we done our intro yet no no we
haven't um hi this is the intro joey's
the host yes hello sonic fans i'm joey
welcome to trash taste i'm with don
connor yeah episode 69 this is
absolutely
intro than that i uh i texted felix uh
earlier when we found out that this was
episode 69 because a little backstory so
uh you know felix would be pewdiepie who
we've been trying to get on the show but
can't come to japan because you know
obviously because of the world situation
so but we hoped that oh yeah you know by
episode 69 hopefully you know he would
have been able to come yeah obviously he
couldn't so uh i uh i texted him and
said i'm sorry man like we didn't didn't
he he didn't he like specifically say
reserved episode 16. he was like joey if
if i'm not on episode 69 i'm just not
coming on because i remember you telling
me that in like episode two or three or
something just when trash tastes started
yeah and i'm just like are we even going
to be around like 2069 like like are we
even gonna have an audience by then i
was like wow felix you're very very like
positive thinker like thinking 65
episodes ahead i was just like i
couldn't even like envision episode 69
because i was just like i'll be happy if
we can last a year yeah honestly
honestly
it's weird to think that we're probably
going to reach 100 episodes that's scary
there's going to be like which episode
of trash taste this in oh it's 179
actually yeah right that's weird to
think that that could be a thing
scary because when i see joe rogan it's
like episode 800 or something yeah [ __ ]
but he doesn't he like record three
episodes a week or something yeah it's
it's like once every two days like holy
yeah like four hours long yeah yeah the
man wants to talk to me [ __ ] i think i
thought i'd run out of topics to talk
about yeah right oh my god i like you
know just sitting through one episode of
joe rogan really makes me appreciate
just how much [ __ ] a he knows and b like
how good he is at like stretching out a
single topic because like no but
seriously because like after like 800
something episodes four hours at a time
right like you have to
like i feel like when you're very you do
talk about current topics and you very
much
but as well like even if it's not our
current topics he's very good at like
kind of like really extensively like
going into the topic to the point where
like you know a topic that can last
maybe what 10 minutes on trash tastes
can last up to an hour on the joe rogan
show people you're really stretching out
that uh 15 minutes
how many can we fit in here
i mean you know when you're when you're
talking about politics you you know they
suddenly turn what could be two minute
conversations into ten hours that is
true yeah maybe we should do that
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
kidding me like i think the reason
people come to watch first is to escape
political nonsense i i come to trash
taste to escape a lot of players
i'm just like i just want to talk with
the boys i just everyone who talks about
it i feel like is no i feel like no one
is educated enough about it and no yeah
and so when everyone talks about it i'm
like i don't know which level of
education you need in this topic but i
feel that no one has enough because
everyone seems to always have some
[ __ ] argument that i'm like what yeah
the [ __ ] is going on right like the prop
the problem with like a lot of political
topics is that the trash taste oh are
you gonna drink water no drink coffee
out of it sorry yeah
because i completely agree because a lot
of the times there are some topics where
you know you just genuinely don't know
you don't know which side to listen to
because both sides are just at each
other's throat and i'm just like i don't
i don't feel like it like every time
someone brings up some kind of political
like conversation because i a just don't
really care about politics in general
and b i'm again not knowledgeable anyway
you don't care about politics in general
that's taking a stance in itself joey
yeah wow
that's that's privileged
but like everything like it doesn't
matter what it is it could be like the
most far-left thing it could be the most
far-right thing and my only two like
answers is just oh that sucks or oh
that's good i guess i keep up with it
but i do also really despise the era
we're in where like it's like all like
everything is political yeah no no it's
it's it's not that everything's
political it's like
everyone has to be involved you know it
has to be educated in it right like
everyone needs an opinion i feel like
the main players are all just like
youtubers and i'm like i don't trust
youtubers i'm a youtuber
i don't trust other youtubers i don't
trust myself yeah
i say i know i know i know
i know what we're like and i know for a
fact that these people cannot be that
doing that good of a job and when i
listen to them i'm like okay this is
fine
you know to me it's like
it's also been highly monetized now yeah
like money has become such a big player
in it that i don't want to watch any of
these people on youtube tell me about
that that's true why they believe ex
person has no rights or whatever yeah
because it's like you've got a horse in
in this race to talk about it yeah you
know you've got to you you've got to get
people angry and upset about it so you
can get dollars there's something in it
for you yeah you know you know which is
why i also hate it a lot and i also just
don't really like talking about it
online because it's it's a [ __ ] show and
also it is everyone has their own
opinions it is a [ __ ] show and like i
just feel like some some things are just
better discussed in private with the
person because there's only there's only
so much you can say in a 140 characters
on twitter and that's unfortunately
where a lot of these opinions are being
spread and like that it's easy to one
misrepresent your own ideas and two
other people to misrepresent your ideas
and take it out of context yeah and it's
just it just seems like a lose-lose
situation for me too i don't like i
don't know
why it's just so bad or why don't more
people just don't just agree that
sometimes you just aren't educated
enough or you just don't know enough
about a topic to just have an opinion
yeah
and you say that and like you know it's
very i feel like there's so many things
now where we just have so much
information on topics where
yeah okay maybe someone can pre you some
two parties can present the same uh
the complete opposite uh argument but
there's enough information where they
can kind of both make their point
because they have enough points that
work with one person and enough points
that work with the other yeah it's like
okay well i can get educated on all of
it and then when you do try and educate
yourself on everything in a certain
situation you just you just realize i
just hate all of this yeah that
everything is just [ __ ] and nothing
works pretty much there's like no right
answer yeah yeah
yeah yeah i i've gotten to that point a
lot of times where it's just like how do
i fix this problem i have absolutely no
[ __ ] clue i don't even know where to
start the more i read the more depressed
life and the rest of the world it's like
first time
no one knows the answer and that's why
we're arguing yeah yeah the whole thing
with like the uh you should reduce your
uh energy uh usage to help combat global
warming and then it's just the whole
thing of but then also like bp is like
spilling the entire oil supply into like
the the ocean and it's like well i feel
like i'm like not really the problem i
feel like it's not really me yeah you
say that and people get angry and then
it's like well
and then you're like well change it we
should we should we should vote against
these companies but that's been proven
that that doesn't
doesn't really [ __ ] work half the
time because clearly someone makes a new
rule that they can go in the the half
past the whole game is busted so no
matter how many times you change the
rules it's just not going to turn out to
be the game that they want to play it
just sucks it sucks it all [ __ ] sucks
it does and that's why we don't talk
about it on trash
it always goes to the negative for me
which is why i'm just like i'm on trash
chase with the boys i just wanna i just
to shut off the internet for a while i
want to talk about how i want to be
reincarnated as a dog
yeah it's okay to stop caring you know
there's just too much yeah there's way
too much
because right now we're just so
overloaded with informations and things
to care about right i literally gotta
like [ __ ] myself if somebody sneezed
within two feet of me now i gotta worry
about what's going on you know
in like multiple countries now i'm a uk
i live in japan
that's the biggest thing that's changed
right because before everyone could
everyone only needed to care about what
was around them right yeah and now being
people on the internet i have to care
about every thing going on globally and
it gets to the point where there are so
many different cultures so many
different so many different points of
view
so many different like experiences that
each individual has had that sometimes
it's impossible for a lot of people to
get the same
same like viewpoint on things because
even for us who've lived in like
multiple countries and have had like
experience with multiple cultures like
you can say we're cultured ourselves
it's like like well like like saying
saying this in like the pure
unironic sense because you get this
sense whenever i go home or whenever i
hear about any of us going home and you
see people who have stayed in their home
towns and you see people who have not
left their hometowns and they have the
exact same viewpoint that they got
raised on right and you know and
coming from the place you kind of you
kind of
you kind of understand how they got that
viewpoint even though you don't agree
with it you know what i mean but you
also understand that they don't have
anything
to really change their viewpoint in
there because they've never experienced
it there's nothing there's no like new
information that comes in to like
stimulate that change in thought process
so forever they just think well this is
correct because this is what was what it
was like around me i don't know about
anything else that's happening in the
world so this is just how i'm going to
see the world but then you know like for
instance like i remember like when i
when i first came back to australia
after i was living here and you know i
would go see like my friends and stuff
like that who have been there like the
entire time like yeah i don't know like
things that i remember i used to be able
to like very heavily relate with and
like kind of almost agree upon i found
myself to be like oh is this is this how
i is this how i felt like is this really
what my thought process was like and
it's like and it's so weird because like
that didn't even happen in
that much of a large space of time like
that only maybe happened in like two
years yeah right i'm just living here
and i think you know like definitely
like doing youtube and stuff like that
has got me to interact with so many more
different
nationalities and you know yeah
yeah you know doing this job like you're
almost forced to be up to date with
everything that's happening around the
world because you have people all over
the world who are viewing you right so
yeah i have this weird pressure of being
like you know i don't want this like one
person from this one country coming into
like my streams or whatever being like
do you know what's happening in my
country right now and me going no i
don't yeah yeah you get that like what
do you think about the current
gentrification of uh southeast uh macau
and you're like what the [ __ ] it's like
i don't think i know that what is macau
if
you're like you surely can't expect me
to have a horse in this race please come
on i'm just killing people from a cow i
know i know i'm accountable
but like that's the thing right it's
like you know you're almost like
pressured to be up to date on that kind
of stuff because you don't want to leave
any of your viewers out and stuff like
that and so that causes you to just like
you know it absorbs so much information
about the world that when i go back to
my hometown and i meet people who aren't
up to date on that kind of stuff who
have completely different viewpoints of
the world because the amount of
information that they've absorbed about
the world is on a different level
it's it's i don't know it's like it's
it's a bit of a whiplash
i can't believe i used to think like
that that's kind of weird i don't even
know my own blood type so i don't even
expect people to like learn about like
the outside you know how do people like
somebody keep up with like weird news in
some country i've never heard of i think
you should be the one to know your own
blood type i should i have a blood
disease as well
i have a blood disease i don't know what
blood type is that
i don't know
he's pretty uh irresponsible yeah you
also had to do like a blood test here
yeah and you weren't showing your blood
type yeah having said that i don't know
my blood type either you know the same
document
i'm just as monkey brain as him
apparently
i know it's in the alphabet like it's
one of them it's in the outside of the
it's one of the four
what is your blood type sigma
delta alpha sigma alpha
decaf i don't know like
i don't know you know and i i do you
know like you said you do try to get
yourself on some things but there's just
like so many you know you can't be
expected to keep up with so many things
like here's a question then like do you
feel like there's a big difference
between explaining to someone that's you
know what kind of your perspective and
actually like
having the person really experience it
and empathize with you because i feel
like those are two different things yeah
i you know i i can i can
sit here i can go back to wales and
explain japanese culture all day and
they just won't understand it yeah
exactly right why would you why would
you do that why would you bow at every
single every every word why would you
say excuse me every set yeah yeah
to me it's kind of like very similar to
let's say learning a language where you
can explain a language you can explain
grammar structures and you can explain
you know how how the writing system
stuff works but there's there's a
difference between understanding how a
language works and actually just
absorbing it and really getting a feel
for the language yourself yeah uh
i know there's a word for it um
acquisition language acquisition is just
you know versus just like learning how
it works on a logical sense and i feel
like i feel the exact same way when it
comes to cultures and perspective where
there's been so many times where someone
has told me about a perspective right
and you logically like yeah i agree with
that you know you you know they could be
making the most sense but then you kind
of maybe move to the country that
they're living in or you go travel there
or you meet more people from that same
culture and you're like oh i think i
actually get what you're talking about
yeah you know like well yeah i think
it's like you know how you know when
you're growing up and you hear about
other countries and you think oh it's
that funny little thing that country
does you know like i know i know like
they would probably do this about japan
a lot they would just show things like
zoom and they'd be like isn't that isn't
that so strange there's big men in
diapers pushing each other around it's
like it's one of those things isn't it
but
i i think that when you get to
experience more cultures your mindset on
on when you see stuff like that changes
a lot like you go from thinking oh that
funny thing that weird strange thing to
think yeah like i'm sure there's a story
behind it i'm sure there's a history
there's a place i definitely felt that
especially after i started dating aki
and you know through youtube meeting a
lot of like americans because like in
australia the image of america is not
that glamorous or like positive in any
way like you know i'm just saying it's
straight up like you know like i think
the image of americans with america is a
lot of americans are often like the
first people to bash them right exactly
i love you america yeah but like you
know it depends on where they're from
yeah it depends yeah but like after you
know actually going to america and
talking to americans and stuff like that
that completely flipped open and i
realized oh it's the problem was just
kind of my environment that was pushing
that agenda and the media that i
consumed that was kind of pushing this
sort of negative agenda about american
culture and stuff like that but then
when you actually go and you live it out
you see it firsthand and you see
everything else that they don't show and
you're like oh actually it's not as like
insane or wacky as like the tv shows or
the the [ __ ] my friends were talking
about make it out to be you know yeah
but
like i remember when i first started
dating sydney right i remember we uh
like when we first when we first met and
first started dating i remember early on
because she mentioned this to me to me
the other day i asked her so would you
like out of curiosity what do you
actually think about america right and
she was like oh greatest country in the
world and i i remember
what she did ask no no she was dead she
came from like imagine it she came from
like a small town in the midwest where
you know when you first started yeah
when i first started dating
five six years ago right right seven
years ago now actually
well it was a long time ago i remember
that was the first time she had
basically like traveled out of america
and she came from a very small town in
the midwest who you know
got raised with the values that you
would expect a small town to get raised
in and
i remember she said oh yeah america is
the greatest country in the world
obviously and i remember apparently she
said i was just like
like that
and she she not her and she and she said
uh she said to me at the time she got
like genuinely offended right
she like she she's straight up she got
like genuinely angry at me at the time
for doing that she was like well jimmy
why and then
why why did you make that sound she said
to me i was like so what constitutes the
greatest country yeah and why is america
the greatest country and she was like oh
land of the free isn't there we got
freedom and i was about the second
second i'm like
you know because like i was about to say
i was like if she's about to drop the
freedom wrong bomb like i i don't know
what i can say to that no because it's
to me at the time it was just like
living up to the stereotypical patriotic
america yeah because like yeah like you
know america is is a good country you
know but like my my issue is the more i
travel with more i'm just like is there
a greatest country in the world and
there's no way you can define the
greatest country in the world otherwise
everyone would be living there yeah
exactly and to me patriotism as a
british person is just so weird like you
see it you i see like american
patriotism where um you know not saying
every american like this but like
especially some of the some of the
americans i've met who have who were
raised in small towns especially when i
go when i go back to sydney's hometown
it's just you you see you see kind of
like this culture and this culture
that's been uh and this idea that's just
been uh propagated through the small
town and there's not not really been any
other perspective to really change that
perspective so by their by
by their uh
by their
like they properly believe by their
belief they probably believe that
america is the greatest country in the
world
uh
and there is no other thing that can
challenge that and it's it's just i'd
like i can't blame them for that
i'm not even saying america isn't the
greatest country in the world i'm just
saying
that
because their belief has been permeated
so deeply that there's been nothing to
really break that mould for them and it
took years for sydney to really kind of
change her perspective it didn't take
like just one trip to england it took
years for traveling to uh to you know
living with me in england and living
with me in thailand and living with me
in japan for her to like really open up
her perspective like you know what maybe
there are some other good places in the
world as well you know
you know maybe some other places do
things yeah that's good yeah and
um and now she has recently just gone
back to america to visit her family yeah
and she's like wow i uh i really don't
fit in here anymore really yeah that's
uh it felt weird because she told me
that she just didn't feel like as
settled as she used to be
just because she she had like she feels
like an outsider almost yeah yeah yeah i
definitely got that when i was uh back
in wales last time i don't know it's you
know i i love my hometown and i love my
friends but you definitely feel like
because you've been
doing so many things and exploring so
many different cultures you definitely
feel like god i must sound like that
weird [ __ ] gap student who come back
yeah i've traveled the world now
i'm better than all of you it's it's
because i really don't want to sound
like that yeah i know but it does it
does open your perspective a lot and you
do think like oh [ __ ] like
it really does make you look at stuff in
your tiny town a lot different
and
you know how how homogeneous the tiny
town just feels so much more tinier yeah
weirdly and and it's like and you know
again like i don't blame like sydney or
anyone from like the small town to think
that way because again like i feel
especially in america it really is just
like kind of enclosed when it comes to
the information that you can get about
the rest of the world like it still
blows my mind that like and like in
america for example like 24-hour news
channels are a thing but it's not world
news it's american use for 24 hours and
i'm like
what
it's just insane to think like this for
one there's so much news happening in
america that you can just constantly run
news stories but also like there's just
so little
access or ease of access to information
outside of america so in the uk though
really we get like we get trickle downs
from america we don't really see a lot
of inside america like
you know a lot of british people don't
really know many of the states outside
of the very famous ones oh i'm sure it's
the same in australia stuff like that
and we have very rudimentary knowledge
of uh
outside of europe really do you guys
have like world news on your tv yeah we
do
yeah but like world news is just mostly
but it's mostly the middle east conflict
that yeah stuff that we [ __ ] up really
stuff that we had to hand in
it's rare that we hear anything about
japan or asia in general that's like
something massive well because of the
olympics normally yeah yeah yeah because
bbc scarcely reports on
japan like i have the bbc app and i said
like the japan section they don't do
like an article every like three days on
japan all right it would be very it'd
probably be quite high profile stuff in
japan yeah very wacky wow
they open up a new store with m m's
but uh also i do think as well the fact
that a lot of people think
one of the reasons why people really
think america is terrible is uh
you know in the uk and also in japan i
feel this as well a lot of this like
bad stuff and injustices if you will in
the uk and i i think japan as well
probably don't get as much
spotlight as they do in america and also
everything is [ __ ] filmed in america
sure literally everything is on camera
in america so like i feel like it's way
easier to catch the stuff that makes
your country look [ __ ] insane yeah
yeah when when you know there's cameras
all the [ __ ] time capturing
everything i feel like the one of the
main reasons why we see so many insane
stuff for america looks good you hear
about all these horrible injustices that
have been done is because there's just
so much video and there's so much
uh attention brought to it by the media
i mean it's also as well the fact that
like you know just simply the population
difference is one thing as well but it's
also again it's just like that whole
cultural mentality or i guess like group
mentality of like it's me versus the
world you know not so much because like
you know it's very much an
individualistic society where it's like
i'm the center we have the uk as well
i think the uk way more i think it's
definitely like that's definitely one of
the biggest difference between east and
west that i've felt living in both
different places yeah yeah and like you
know whereas in japan it's like oh i
don't want to i don't want to stick out
too much because otherwise a camera
might get stuck on but it's hard right
because on one hand you get you get a
society where you know everyone's
comfortable nobody nobody oversteps
their boundaries but everyone's [ __ ]
miserable so exactly so it's like you
know
you know you can't have the this utopian
ideal japan without also being very
having a depressed society where no one
can have fun and i feel that's like the
problem right now is that like yeah
regardless of if you're an
individualistic society versus a
collective society there's still [ __ ]
that happens
the stuff i love about the uk is also
i'm near certain the stuff that i love
or is also the reason why we have a lot
of the stuff i don't like about this
yeah yeah exactly uh you know i mean
same thing with japan yeah yeah so it's
you don't you don't get the good things
there's no there's no perfect country
there's no perfect country and i don't
think there's a place denmark's just
like hello
switzerland but also i love that i read
an article that was like people who live
in denmark that are unhappy are
extremely unhappy because they're
supposed to be the happiest country on
earth right yeah yeah so the people who
get sad there or their life isn't going
the way they want they feel more
depressed because they're supposed to be
because everyone around them is happy
yeah it's supposed to be the happiest
place on earth
like no matter what goes wrong you can't
win but i think obviously if uh you know
that that also depends on you know if
you can afford to be healthy and all
that stuff so that that all changes yeah
being healthy is pretty good
this video is sponsored by expressvpn
did you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode no i don't think i did
well it says that your activity might
still be visible to your employer your
school or your internet service provider
how could they even call it
incognito it's okay connor you can stop
crying okay because to really stop
people from seeing the sights you visit
you need to do what i do get expressvpn
holy [ __ ] everything's fixed
think about all the times you've used
wi-fi at a coffee shop a hotel or even
your parent's house oh my god without
expressvpn every site you visit could be
logged by the admin of that network oh
gosh and that's still true even if you
use incognito mode what's more i just
found out that your home internet
provider can also record your browsing
data see
and in the us they're legally allowed to
sell that data to advertisers see what
is an expressvpn is the app that
encrypts all of your network data and
reroutes it through a network of secure
services that your private all activity
stays there just that privacy
oh my god expressvpn also works on all
of your devices hell yeah the app
literally has one button you tap to
connect to it and your browsing activity
is secured from prying eyes so stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.comtaste
use our link at
expressvpn.comtaste to get three extra
free months free that's
expressvpn.comtaste to learn more i
can't handle back to the episode are you
guys patriotic
ah no
only in like sport whales yeah yeah like
pretty much the most patriotic i get is
towards sports but like you have to like
okay so i think well whale's patriotic
and and being in the uk is a very
different uh how many times how often do
you get to be patriotic about wales
any time england [ __ ] up
that's basically right
yeah yeah exactly basically that's what
i'm saying it's not uh it's not
patriotism in wales is not like the rest
of the world patriotism right now go us
it's just [ __ ] england yeah i i feel
like that's just literally that's just
scotland and irish like uh northern
irish yeah patriotism that's that's why
i feel like uk patriotism is a
completely different brand to other yeah
because because it's you know we get
very proud of welsh people obviously but
we get the most proud when it when it is
to the detriment of england
yeah so you know when people are like oh
you're like english though right it's
like no i'm not even i have no there's
absolutely nothing about me that is
english
i'm i'm british and welsh but not
english yeah yeah so yeah a lot of
people always like that that's english
right
no no no no i despise but but i only i
despise it in a very fun way you know
yeah it's very much like
uh yeah there's a lot of fun stories
banter right yeah yeah have you watched
archer the tv show uh little bits of
yeah yeah there's a really weird thing
that just completely caught me off guard
so um they did an episode about like
a very um famous welsh event that
happened and it was very weird that our
archer an american comedy tv show did
this yeah so there's a thing called uh
truearin in wales right and uh it's a
small town uh that no longer exists okay
because uh liverpool which is a a city
in england uh wanted a reservoir so
their solution to getting a reservoir
was to just flood this town
so they could get water holy [ __ ] i
assure you not so they had to evacuate
they literally just made people just
move wow okay and whilst people weren't
allowed to vote on whether this was yeah
so they had no say they'd know so right
so they just flooded this town called
troaden and turned it into a reservoir
turned out they didn't even need it in
the end
and then they they killed like four
people as well because some people
refused to leave holy [ __ ] so they they
flooded it
you can go there it's depressing as [ __ ]
because they're just like buildings
underneath this reservoir
and there's a bunch around the area
there's a ton of like remember remember
and it's just it's seen as one of the
most like
injustices that were done to work yeah
that's pretty funny it's pretty shitty
fairly recent as well how recent we're
talking
i think 60s can you google it it's right
60s 80s around that time i think just
troading t-r-y
sure that's just the plot to higarash
like didn't he
they were like going to build a dam and
then they'll like protest and like stop
the people
so english people could drink water and
then they didn't even use it
like it's it's like what the [ __ ] and
then also archer just did an episode
about it absolutely
they did a whole thing of like they were
like
like a whole joke about it because like
they were like it's one of the most
enjoy and they were all like like nah
don't worry about it yeah justice
wow that's something everyone needs to
care about that is something yeah
you're all educated on the true adam i
mean that's the very basic story there's
a lot more yeah there's other people can
tell
i feel like when you're from a small
nation that just doesn't get a lot of
attention from the world media in
general because that's that's me
whenever like
thailand gets mentioned anywhere right
like like i i'm just happy if like
thailand is just brought up in any kind
of capacity i'm just everyone everyone
knows my country now that's uh i love it
they get like insanely excited and like
anything happens like they're just
insane it's great i remember i went
passionate about anything yeah right i
remember when i went to a con in
singapore uh the comments were like
shouting at you in public yeah no no no
yeah that one but like i remember i did
a i did a panel there and i literally
all i literally said was hello singapore
and i've never heard a crowd of people
like crying and screaming
it was as if like [ __ ] elvis presley
came on stage and like said their
country's name it's like he said the
country name ladies and gentlemen
honestly the singapore convention was
like crazy that was insanely [ __ ] the
most i wasn't i wasn't invited i wasn't
invited i mean i wasn't invited i was
just there for the ride yeah because i i
was we weren't tied at this point when i
wasn't
you know we knew each other i was yeah
yeah i'm just on the other side of the
world yeah i was already in thailand i
was literally just next yeah like he's
like i'm gonna pop down to singapore
yeah no the guy literally texted me and
was like oh you're in singapore finna
pop down for a quick second
yeah it's it's it's so weird sometimes
where what we are as southeast asians
are proud of sometimes because like it's
like i swear to god every time i meet a
fellow southeast asian from a different
country we get competitive over like the
weirdest things right because the first
thing we compare is um how [ __ ] it is to
drive on our roads yeah
like i don't know why we do that is it
like it's like yo you're still alive
nice
why is just like oh this one time in
bangkok i was in traffic for one hour oh
when i oh you think one hour is bad when
i was in jakarta it was a three hour
traffic jam once and i'm just like
thinking about this i'm just like why
are we comparing why would this is like
the weirdest dick size comparison i can
think of oh you survived two car crashes
i survived four
like that's not something to be proud of
because i was just like i caused all of
them
because after living in two years sydney
just went around to other people being
like you know thailand has like thailand
is like second on like the most
dangerous place to drive in the world
right and i lived there and i'm just
like cindy why are you why are you
posting about like why did i even drive
there
why are we boasting about that
she's saying all this like in the
passenger seat
it's like when i went here go to my
university town was like number one for
like heroin usage in the uk
yeah number one yeah
number one
number one whales let's go
like where i grew up was like number one
for like teen pregnancy in the uk as
well yeah and then there was just like a
fact they were like good be proud of it
we're finally number one in something
so all of your parents here are still
teenagers congratulations that's kind of
what it's like in a small town yeah i
just i just realized that's exactly
where the same way as where sydney comes
from the first thing she boasts about uh
from like wisconsin it's just like two
things we are like we're like cheese
we're like number one in cheese beers
and cereal killers
just like i don't i don't think that's a
good thing sydney being number one in
cheese in the us is not a that's like
saying you know you're number one
landlocked country in like some [ __ ]
i don't know town i don't know [ __ ] this
terrible comparison but i know what you
mean it's like it's it's not something
to be like oh wow amazing i mean what is
amazing is the fact that [ __ ] that
state is the most serial killers like
that's that's pretty impressive honestly
i liked uh
the midwest it's pretty chill where have
you been in the midwest i really like
minnesota minnesota probably my favorite
state i've been to in the us i got
deported from there
yes sir sir
you said they were really really nice
though when they were deporting you
though no they weren't nice because
they weren't nice about it at least they
were like hey it's not your fault man it
happens all the time kind of thing but
you also have to uh fly immediately to
amsterdam and then from amsterdam back
to tokyo you're allowed to say why you
got deported is that like something you
want to talk about oh just visa mix-ups
basically i mean like you've got the
wrong visa right yeah basically i had
the wrong visa apparently i asked the uh
the immigration officer in minnesota he
was like yeah this this happens all the
[ __ ] times like it's like you are
definitely not in the wrong for not
knowing this [ __ ] like it is really
confusing um but he's like just go home
get this particular visa and then you'll
be good for like the next 10 years at
least sometimes it sounds really cool
seeing you deported
yeah
until you get deported yeah yeah yeah
i'm sure getting deported wasn't cool no
getting deported wasn't cool but the
fact that i literally flew around the
world in 48 hours yeah you just did a
[ __ ] speed run i i did basically
speed ran like around the world yeah
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] took them 80
days the first time you know what i mean
i went to the us i didn't know you knew
the visa right i was like what
so so what happened was that we did we
didn't need a visa before
no we did do we need the esther how
about that that was introduced pretty
recently yeah the esta before before the
esther you didn't need it yeah the first
time went to america you didn't need an
esther how long ago was this esther was
like 10 15 years ago yeah something like
that it was within my lifetime that the
uh the
the the legislation changed well because
you know you've been traveling through
europe all my life and i just assumed
you just turn out where you want to go
oh yeah i mean that
so i didn't know that and so i booked my
flight to the u.s this is when the
esther was a thing yeah which is
[ __ ] because america can come to the
uk no no no documentation needed just a
passport oh yeah when we when we have to
go to america we have to get this esther
nonsense right yeah so i'm i'm i'm
getting all my stuff ready this is my
first flight ever to america i'm on my
own oh my god and then it's like
midnight and on my flight like 9am my
dad came in my room he's like did you
get the visa i'm like what
what do you mean
yeah you gotta get a visa i might who no
one told me this how do i get the visa
about i'm like 19 as well i've never
heard of this yeah when do i have to get
a visa yeah and luckily uh apparently
supposed to get it three days before
yeah three days uh but yeah like more
than three days before yeah but luckily
it came in 15 minutes yeah yeah yeah i
was very lucky i also did that in japan
as well that was very yeah aki had to do
that at the airport once because like
she realized her esther had run out you
just have a really [ __ ] track record at
uh getting into country so yeah i just i
i'm losing your passport before we go to
japan oh yeah yeah i remember that i
totally forgot because it only lasts for
two years when you go to the us you have
to get uh from most countries and also
canada if you get one too yeah you just
apply for a thing called nesta cost 15
you do it online if your passport is
like normal you have like no criminal
record or anything you should get it in
like 15 minutes yeah like immediately
but do it three days just in case that's
why they suggest you um yeah and it
lasts two years and when i moved to
japan i was going to go to san francisco
and i totally forgot it expired until i
was on the way to the airport when i
realized it had expired so i was
applying for it on my phone yeah on the
way and luckily right before i was about
to check in i just got it oh nice i was
like nice that's gold split right there
yeah
yeah i told my company i'm like uh hey
uh i forgot to uh get the esther they
were like what
what and i was like yeah so uh i applied
for it it should be fine we'll see i'll
see
we'll see
luckily it all worked out at least yeah
at least you weren't like on the plane
when you realized that yeah yeah yeah
it's weird though because they don't ask
me for it and they don't ask me for
their they don't ask you for the asked
at any point so i wonder is it just on
like a system and they they only ask you
for it when you're immigrating into the
country that you just landed
no they they asked they they should what
what uh airline did you fly with british
airways they never they've never asked
me for it because because i normally get
asked
when i'm queuing up to check in
if if i have a visa yeah they know there
are more they never
excuse me sir
excuse me sir do you have a visa to get
into our country
this is really my privilege right now
[ __ ]
no but like i like especially coming
from uh having dual citizenship in a uk
and thailand it's just like it just
makes me realize man we are very
privileged to have certain passports
because it it's it's it's it is
literally just some passports are
completely useless
yeah japan is like the most
op passport most powerful possible in
the world but yeah but no but only like
20 people have them here can you believe
that yeah the [ __ ] audacity and also
yeah it's there's there's so many like
weird other rules that come with it and
also and again it's like yeah as you
were saying it's the most powerful
possible in the world and yet barely any
japanese people fly out of japan because
the tourism industry here is just so
powerful
i completely forgot i was gonna i was i
was just gonna say that some some
parcels are like pretty op and
uh like that's that's that makes me
jealous of your japanese passport
because
you can get in like what what what can
japan get in without a visa that the uk
can't i'm sure there's something i'm
sure
i'll put it on the screen
obviously
i don't think about this but i think
like in the uk it's something like 70 to
80 people have a passport in america
it's like yeah it was so weird for me
going to a country and just like meeting
people without a passport yeah everyone
just has one in the uk yeah everyone i
know has one yeah in australia as well
like almost everyone has one yeah yeah i
guess i guess it's just like a
difference in culture right because like
i couldn't imagine not having a passport
what's what are you gonna go and do in
the uk just go to like a field and be
like sick this is great vacation or i
could also get a passport go to another
country and go to that field yeah yeah
exactly but like you know we've seen our
beaches yeah yeah
someone who's born up in brighton oh we
have amazing beaches
you want sand beaches no we got we've
got stone stones you can't even walk on
it uk tourism is the most depressing
thing on earth like it's just [ __ ]
what would you recommend
to someone who's never been to the uk
i when people come to the uk
[Music]
no no no go go to london because you
think you're right is that the reason
why i think the uk works as a tourist
destination is because you don't know
anything about it yeah you know about
the uk it's this terrible place i think
most people's imaginations of the uk is
the queen harry potter and
well the thing is if you go to london
you get a very sanitized view of london
of the uk and you can have a great time
because you you only see london right
london is like very well kept the
charming part yeah it's very well you
know all of them all the [ __ ] money's
in london i'd say some some of the
countrysides are pretty good as well
yeah which is why i really appreciate it
when i meet people who like love castles
and love going around wales and stuff
like that i'm like nice
yeah honestly if you want to go to the
countryside though i'd say ireland is
better island's [ __ ]
i
first found out that people just didn't
live near castles i thought that was
weird when i first found that out yeah i
lived near three castles growing up and
i was like
see like out of context that sounds so
[ __ ] privileged
why what what are you gonna do with it
what's not my casual but that's the
thing but that's the thing like it's
it's like it's like that if you said
that to a japanese person they'd be like
what are you like the prince of wales no
it's just because you know you there's
so many [ __ ] castles in the uk one of
them was very dangerous and run down and
like climbing it was just like a safety
hazard i don't know how it's still
allowed you like to go right dude but
you know there's there's one really cool
castle in me it's like called
i feel whales to castles is very much
japan to temples
yeah yeah maybe you know because like i
think if you said to someone who has
like no idea of like asian culture or
anything like that and said like oh yeah
there's like three temples around my
house they'd be like whoa you're [ __ ]
bougie japan did have a lot of castles
they all just burnt down well yeah
most of them are gone
there is one and there's a really big
one in what kochi there's a massive one
yeah
a lot of them though are recreations
yeah yeah that was like built much much
later i think there's only like a
handful of castles like from that time
that are still standing well a lot of
the ones in the uk are run down as well
like the the out of the three near me
one of them is well kept and that's
mainly for tourist reasons right and the
other two are completely run down and
just like but it's cool that it's a
bunch of rubble but you can pick but you
can buy that right like you can purchase
that as properties some of them
some places normally the big ones you
can't they're normally heritage sites so
you can't buy them they're like public
and at that point people who buy just
buy for flex because who actually lives
in a castle nowadays i believe i read
something about france or something as
the most abandoned castles and the most
castles for sale out of it like any
country oh really apparently you can
just buy shadows and castles
all nonsense that's pretty bougie all
right you say you say uk is good for
travel or i've never said that well what
did you say you say come to the uk he
said just go to london go to london okay
well okay genuine question someone
someone's coming to travel to the uk you
want to show them you want to show them
british culture what'd you say what'd
you take them to first of all the one
question you have to ask someone who
comes to the uk do you drink
[Applause]
you love drinking with people you can
have a two-week trip and you have a
great time yeah if you don't drink
alcohol here's a three-day criteria if
you don't drink alcohol i hope you like
castles
you know i genuinely think because you
can do nearly everything in london
that's worth seeing in one day like one
or two days one or two two two two two
right but but you know like all the
major things are within walking distance
each other
did you take them to like the tourist
tourist sites and everything like that
yeah very fast i'm like here's booking
in palace have a look all right here's
the big ben have a look it's [ __ ] don't
pay it it's like ninety dollars to go on
it it's rip off don't do it oh when we
went it was in [ __ ] scaffolding yeah
yeah right so i didn't even get to see
it all right sorry london eyes [ __ ] big
ben looks pretty cool actually i like it
but you know normally it's like you want
to see big ben we can we can go and
drink in the park in front of big ben
yeah and do that yeah that's cool you
know there's the arcade that's now
closing it's closed now yeah
is that the one with shrek at the front
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's like
it was like yeah that's an arc there's a
namco fanscape there was a [ __ ] arcade
that's closing but it was the only
arcade um what else can you do in london
um maybe take them on the boat
on the boat so you know how like you
know there's public transport there's
the tube part of the network is a boat
there's a oh like like a ferry system
that you can just cross the yeah
i think greenwich to westminster
yeah um yeah greenwich i really like
taking people to granite scrunch is a
really nice area you can go and i can be
like look here's where time started
yeah that's all i know about greenwich
it's a very nice area actually it's
really well done um there's like a
warship in belfast
in front of the united states belfast is
like six hours away you can't go to
belleville the the the warship the uh
the uh
it's right in front of the uh house the
uh
what's that right right next to the
bridge uh greenwich
um the uh where where the other where
are you talking about the sss belfast
yeah
oh that one i i don't know don't know
that one either there's the if you've
got a greenwich as well there's a
massive boat that's been restored on
land it's [ __ ] massive damn um do
they actually collaborate
they should the uk government should
hire me i'll make criteria i'll make uh
what would you add
um spoons go to weatherspoons
tesco
yeah
we went to the shrek arcade in spoons i
went to the uh [ __ ] uh gaming bar as
well
it was like gaming mode
it was literally just a pub with a wii
in it
you really came in that far british
culture man you're just so sick because
like pubs in london are like yeah where
all the best food are as well yeah all
the best to be fair that pub did have
some good food because because the way i
see it right because the way i see it
when i go travel to a place i very
rarely want to go to the big tourist
spots right
yeah i want good place i want cool
places to see but just like not the here
here's just a landmark that uh everyone
takes a [ __ ] picture around i just
want cool local places and like as
someone who lived in london for like
close to three years if it doesn't
revolve around alcohol i don't know the
cool places to take people oh there's
this afternoon tea afternoon oh
afternoon tea and actually that the home
of afternoon tea yeah of course of
course of course i completely forgot
about afternoon tv that's pretty much
the only part of like british food that
i'm just like yep afternoon team [ __ ]
slaps um to be fair i feel australia
would be the exact same thing if it
wasn't for the fact that we have some of
the best beaches in the world yeah like
because it's like because like at least
we can take you to the beach you got it
easy man yeah but like if but if you
don't like beaches then i hope you like
drinking because we're going to be doing
a lot of that
yeah it's kind of hard i've had friends
normally americans who are like no i
don't drink and i'm like i honestly
don't know what to do
i can show you big ben
yeah i i have the same thing when i when
like friends come to australia and i
have to take them around like a couple
times i'm like do you want to see
the opera house i swear
i'm not an alcoholic but it's just the
culture
i don't know what to do
that's kind of why i wanted to move out
of england because it just felt like if
you didn't drink then there was nothing
else to do to have fun or like just just
like chill out that's a big thing
no one does anything on weekdays in the
uk like weekdays is strictly for working
and then going home and being depressed
that's all you do i feel that's no one
goes out in the uk it's always the
weekend
oh really even like even after work nah
no one really goes out really
yeah
it's normally older people they normally
will go after the pub after work when
they're like 40s because they kiss it
well i would love you know some people
go to the pub after work no i know i i
if i've worked in an office i would love
to go but i was a youtuber no one wanted
to go out in the weekdays
who's an absolute uphill battle trying
to get people to do anything in the uk
you have to wait till the weekend yeah
so i never did anything during the
weekend i just worked on videos i think
and played video games i don't really
know what i did
i don't know what i did in london what
did i do what did i do in london i don't
know i went to coffee we have really
good cafes
do we yeah we do
compared to europe
we are we were in europe you guys are
europe we were europe well we're not
we're not in europe anymore because it's
easy to get stuff from like italy and
whatever that's true that's true that's
one thing i miss about that that sucks
about japan is that importing anything
from europe is like 20 times the price
well yeah it's like a block of cheese
that i would pay 10 pounds for on the uk
imported from france is now which is
seen as like a luxury expense
first time i was in australia like
literally on the side of the planet it's
depressing i i bought a wine bottle and
i looked at it and it was like 30 pounds
in the uk yeah and it was like 90 pounds
here in japan
yeah
which is which is like such a like flip
to whenever
well
when someone's going to come visit us in
japan because like you like like when a
friend comes to visit in japan you're
just like what kind of experience do you
want because you could do anything you
can do anything yeah you want to see
nature do you want to see the city do
you want to see culture yeah did you
ever get sick ushering people around
japan because you were always the go-to
guy you had to take people around yeah
yeah i was but uh after a while
it depends who i'm with like if i'm if
i'm with like a person who i'm not like
you know like super buddy buddy with
them obviously you know i want them to
have a good time and have a good
impression but if i'm just like you know
it's just like a [ __ ] mate from
school or whatever yeah then i used to
do this thing where i would take them to
all these places but then pretend i
couldn't speak a word of japanese
just to piss them off because i was like
i don't want to be the translator this
week so you know what let's see how you
like
so we would go to a restaurant and i
would be reading the menu and i'll be
like uh eggo menu onegaishimasu just
[ __ ] pretend that i was foreign
because if i don't speak japanese
they'll never [ __ ] know yeah yeah so
they were just like come on just [ __ ]
help us help me translate this [ __ ]
thing and i was like nihongo and i i'm
sorry
yeah japan is just like local guide easy
mode yeah right you you can [ __ ] you
go to like a [ __ ] family mod and they
like blow their minds yeah right like i
just i just take them like ikebukuro and
it's done for the day yeah i know right
you can listen
to one one place yeah in tokyo and
that's their entire itinerary done for
the day yeah honestly it's time for a
ramen place like oh my god it's ramen
yeah it's like well that's the thing
right if you take them to like shibuya
you're easily like two days you could
spend there yeah if you take knockout
bro that's a whole day again you're
taking me haha it's like several days
yeah oh yeah cause you're gonna have one
day and they're like
can we can we go back to akihabara
please i miss i missed when i thought
akihabara was like super fun and amazing
as well well
just because all the figures you know
that the prices are always cheaper
elsewhere i've just found that the more
the the more times i've gone to arcabra
the more i realized that there was just
so much cool hidden [ __ ] there that
really if you're not there with someone
who knows the area really well it really
just does seem like here's the place to
buy anime figurines he's the bi he's the
place to bite yeah i just don't have the
time to explore it anymore yeah that's
true also
nearly all the restaurants i've been to
in akihabara are like severely
disappointed awesome i mean it's awful
awful i i said
i've had probably the worst meals in
japan consistently yeah
yeah i don't know i think because it's
just on the front and then you know
everyone's like come on our store well
that's the thing it's like no one really
like no one really thinks to themselves
oh i want a really nice meal let's go to
oculus i hate the maids who are like
come on austral please please please
yeah that is really annoying and the
like igor dies your boo and i'm like
[ __ ] off
then get this of course
i'm british i say it in my head i'm like
please leave me alone nice just human
interaction get get out of here get out
get out of here
[Laughter]
one time we walked past and there was a
maid that was like joey jam with that
she started like screaming like one of
the maids what's the mate well who
recognized me yeah yeah i remember
this how do you remember this i don't i
wait there actually what happened was i
was with you we were walking and i saw
the girl looking at you yeah and we kept
on walking and then i just heard her go
joey oh yes
and you i feel like you didn't pay any
attention you were like whatever and
just kept walking then i was like
i do remember that actually because it's
like yeah i heard her say my name
but i thought like i didn't hear it as
my name until i walked past her and then
a process i was like i think she was
calling my name but then at that point
it was too late to like turn around and
be like
[Music]
me i don't want to be that guy right i'm
famous yeah he's like i'll just be the
cool guy just keep walking i just i i i
feel so unguarded whenever i get
recognized in japan yeah right
it really catches me
yeah it really is scary because i i
don't know like one it's surprising to
hear someone speak english as well here
and just or just on the streets and two
like someone who speaks english and also
recognizes you and it's especially i
think since trash taser started as well
like i don't know how i'm gonna handle
going to my next anime convention and
there's just to be like 70 million
people calling me grant and i'm just
like i'm not going to be able to tell
the difference
like if they're just memeing or if they
actually think my name is grant i have
people at the airport they're like
welcome god grant sorry
yeah because i remember like people
already [ __ ] up my username they're like
yo you're the anime guy right i was like
you're the anime dude and i'm like i
can't wait to just be called like all
these [ __ ] nicknames i'm just like i
don't do you actually know who i am or
you just like taking the pierce
because sometimes i don't even know like
when some when when a person comes up to
me and goes are you the anime guy i i
don't know if i'm supposed to go
i'm the anime man or if i'm supposed to
go nah who's that who's that i'm not
that good who is that i don't know i
don't know who that guy is why hello
there it is i anime zone and while
conor's not here i'm going to hijack
this podcast to talk about anime because
you know what this episode is sponsored
by crunchyroll this fall season
crunchyroll is simulcasting a bunch of
new seasons of classics like boruto case
closed and of course the demon slayer
commits from the yuba mugen train tv arc
and entertainment district ark not to
miss the season one piece is airing its
one thousandth episode can you believe
it and a lineup of fresh titles like
platinum n sucker gun and blade runner
black lotus as you know i am the last
remaining trash taste member who
actually watches anime and i know that
platinum inn comes from a manga that was
made by the same team that made death
notes so i am very curious and hyped to
watch it as always you get the biggest
catalogue of anime content with over 30
000 anime episodes available to you to
watch in both sub and dub you can watch
all these titles for free on crunchyroll
or try their 14 day free trial of their
premium membership to skip all the ads
and access simulcasting with japan
follow the link on screen or go to
crunchyroll.com trash chase to start
watching anime today because you're
going to be doing better than the rest
of the boys that's crunchyroll.com trash
taste thank you to crunchyroll for
sponsoring us today back to the episode
yeah have you guys ever been recognizing
your home country have we talked about
this taste before i don't know well i i
feel like it's going to be even more
insane now
tell me what you've been recognized in
the uk i mean i've actually been yeah
i've been recognized once i feel i think
in an argus in brighton oh gosh yeah
[ __ ]
um oh god it's a terrible storm so it's
the whole gimmick of this the whole
gimmick of this store is that you don't
actually like get to look at the
products
it's a warehouse but you get to look at
the massive like 10 page no 10 page 400
page book and you get oh is this the
place where you were talking about like
your christmas gifts or whatever yeah
yeah basically just imagine amazon i
accept you you have to go there and you
don't have a computer screen to browse
everything you just have a massive book
notice how they're still in business
yeah
that seems sounds very outdated it's
kind of like it's kind of like the
blockbuster you recognize yeah
yeah it's really weird it's just one of
the cashiers recognize me it's not a
very exciting story
have you ever gotten that before like
someone working at an establishment
recognize you and you got like a thing
out of it no but if they do i'm very
open
it's but like i've heard stories about
uh now about some of well sydney just
went back to america and apparently she
was just in a bar
and uh she got recognized and uh
that's not good that's not good it's
sydney's content yeah yeah yeah
well she was she got recognized because
uh she was obviously my fiance and she
was just
another guy i said was just uh oh yo are
you sydney and she's like yeah oh
where's gone
she's like oh he didn't come here and i
was like oh say arigan for me
[Applause]
don't do that don't do that don't don't
do that would be like say hi to joey and
garnett yeah
and what what am i gonna say yeah what
yeah
by the way random dude i just met says
hi it's like what do we say to that look
it's like we appreciate you guys coming
up to us and saying hi that's cool and
all but like don't don't like make us be
the messenger for another person that's
right that's no one appreciates
you know the 800th century i'm not a
messenger i'm not like here to convey
messages for you right i got recognized
one time at um midnight on a bus which
was terrifying oh god i was going to the
gym um
and yeah the the bus went right outside
my house to the gym right it was perfect
it was 24 hours as well so it's good
and i was on my way back from the gym i
was extremely sweaty and there's only
two people on this bus me and him and he
was right at the back wearing a hoodie
in the back just like oh [ __ ] and i was
like what the [ __ ] so then um i i'm
sitting close to the front on the second
level yeah and i'm just listening to
music
and i'm like yeah
and then i feel like a
on my back
that's scary and i'm like
i'm like what what he's like
hey man you see dog
and i was like yeah yeah i'm serious
what's up he's like love your videos
and i'm like thanks man and just walked
off
so like i was like
that's so scary
i was like what he was like still hoodie
and everything on when he came up yeah
it's like you see dog just brick [ __ ]
else yeah he was massive and i was like
oh thanks man nice i was like this is my
house
i got i got recognized uh in in
akihabara you see i recognize a lot
obviously yeah every time i should go
with you there it was like i always i
feel that's where my people are i feel
like akihabara is like a cheat code
right because that's like saying you got
recognized at an anime convention yeah
because also akihabara surprisingly has
like the most uh like foreigners yeah it
does and obviously i mean it's it's one
of the most like you know
sensationalized like wacky lookout
places right in tokyo but uh i was
recognizing i get recognized for pretty
much every time i go to akihabara but
the one time i uh went to you know i was
like running a little running a little
short on my on my hentai might uh might
pop into a melon books which is a store
where you can buy hentai and uh
and uh you know peruse the the goods oh
[ __ ] are you the anime man yeah and as i
was perusing through some stuff i got a
tap on the shoulder and it's like are
you joey i'm like i thought she'd be
like the lolly section
the wrong place man and he's like yeah
well i'm like yeah i am high and i was
like oh no like of all like and i was
like holding a dog and i was about to
buy as well and i'm like worst timing
and and you know he had like a bag as
well so he obviously just like finished
at the cash register and the guy was
like what are you doing here i'm like
what the [ __ ] do you think i'm doing
here i jack off like really like really
are you are you sure you're a fan of me
because if you are you would know
exactly what i am doing here
i am holding the thing i am about to buy
you can see that so i'm like so all i
said was just
just buying some hunter
and it's like oh sick dude
all right bye
we just walked out it's just like what
kind of interaction can you have in that
place because i i have exactly the same
experience because the place i can't
recognize the most is that yeah it's
melon books right it starts it's all
right i've been recognized like three
times in a melon books and i'm like why
why is it just like a dojin store yeah
it's just like a complete
store yeah basically when sydney is just
like running out of ideas for content
she just goes there yeah and she's like
oh this is in the cashews like is
are like the two like big big hentai
stores now i always get recognized and i
haven't been recognized often but when i
do it's always when i look like [ __ ]
it's never it's never when i've made an
effort to look good it's never in the
jojo suit you know it's never when i've
got my drip game on yeah it's what i
mean
how often are you interested
every single day
i just you know i remember
one time i went to like there was a
saints reason in me which is just a
normal supermarket yeah yeah and i was
wearing sweatpants flip-flops you know
the [ __ ] which i actually don't even
normally do that i would normally i
would normally put the effort into our
jeans yeah yeah actually no i lied no
just back when i thought that wearing
jeans was a luxury
if i was working why why is it a luxury
uh it doesn't work so i okay actually
i'm going to go on a detour because it
was a [ __ ] story anyway i basically got
recognized as sweatpants
so i had this thing for a very long time
well this isn't this isn't a meeting
this is a general thing i used to just
only wear like sweatpants when i was at
home if i wasn't leaving the house i
wouldn't wear jeans i would just wear
sweatpants i still do that but now
i changed my mind and now i only wear
jeans in the house
what how do you how do you bring
yourself to do that i do that what
because
what happened was that i started just
feeling like [ __ ] i'm just like not
working right so i was like maybe if i
like dress like i'm not a slob i might
work a little better no you you laugh
but it's it's it's a real [ __ ] thing
it actually works like i i i wear jeans
not because i want to but because it's
the only way i'm going to look but when
you wear in when you're wearing a pair
of jeans nicely they feel like better
than anything i i feel like my day
hasn't started until i put all my put on
my sometimes i try to work like an
american fighting for freedom
i just hadn't started my day until i put
on my denim jeans
honestly like so sometimes i try to work
and i'm in like sweatpants or sometimes
just in my [ __ ] boxes because i just
i sleep in my boxes and i just don't get
anything done right as soon as i put on
my jeans the day is started
i am ready to work i don't know man i i
just wake up and go time to work and
then i just don't think you've if you go
mine doesn't matter man yeah but if you
go to jeans you just work harder
you know and like one time i even went
so far as to start wearing like nice
shirts like like like a suit shirt but
yeah but suit shirts when i was making
videos because i was like i was
convinced that this is the next step to
increasing my productivity yeah it turns
out it didn't work and i just hated it
yeah right but i i i found the happy
medium but jeans and a shirt i felt like
if i can dress enough like a t-shirt or
like a college shirt not like this oh
yeah yeah but like i i think the
sweatpants were the big
big player because i basically got to
the mindset of i want to wear outfits
that i could just go out to any social
gathering or
i can wear this to anywhere you know
right and so i felt like it helped my
productivity so if you work at home a
lot and you've you've gone to habit of
sweat pantsing all the time
you know maybe just try wearing what you
would wear to work but what what okay
well what would you do during the summer
then i should still work just like full
on jeans
ac blasting
i mean i i wear whatever i i would wear
to the trash taste office that's
basically like my dress code at home but
like i would never wear anything too
comfy i guess because if i feel if
comfort is the enemy of productivity
well because if i'm being sweatpants i
just like i feel like i should be in my
bedroom or yeah no i get that watching
tv one thing i do one one thing i do in
the morning to like get me into like the
work mode if i'm at home all day is that
i don't wear like my pajama shirt i like
change to a different shirt shirt you
have a pajama shirt yeah just like old
shirts that i don't wear shirts to bed
why don't you do that
i wear shoes to bed cause i don't want
to why people do this because i don't
want to be naked because i just it just
feels like i don't have advices just
boxes i don't know it just doesn't feel
comfortable yeah if it feels like a it
feels like unless i'm in a sleeping bag
i don't have enough cover over me yeah i
feel really bare yeah
and unprotected like like boxes
i love using the body parts as
temperature control so i put some out
put some in you know depending on how
much how cold the heart needs to be
okay but do you okay do you wear boxes
to bed yeah sometimes naked sometimes
boxes see are like i need to wear boxes
to bed sleeping like completely naked
just feels weird
used to thing you know because the nut
sack is a very delicate thing to kind of
like
you laugh but nothing
because nuts go everywhere and sometimes
they're more elastic than other times so
it's uh
sometimes you just don't want you're not
sack rubbing against your leg you know
like i don't know like for me you're not
you're not so huge that they're like a
[ __ ] sack of potatoes like oh [ __ ] it
out of the way when when i'm not wearing
a shirt to sleep it just feels weird to
feel my own skin on my skin no i get
that like like you know you know it's
it's exactly the same like the only time
i will you've been like brainwashed the
other time the only time where i will go
to bed without a shirt on is if it's
like excruciatingly hot to the point
where like even the ac on blast isn't
going to do it for me yeah
like i mean like i mean like i need some
fabric on me too yeah
i feel like you're just like giving me a
very shitty reason as to why you weren't
sure to bet it's comfortable end of
story i just i don't understand why you
would feel uncomfortable without the
shirt okay and another thing sometimes
sometimes if i'm not wearing a shirt my
body gets even hotter right because you
have like a natural body temperature and
if it's like skin on skin sometimes it
like it's like a it's like a loop system
where like warms itself up a bit more
i don't know if that's just me i think
that's [ __ ] i think you've got
surely insulation shirt keeps in the
skin uh the heat more no no i mean like
insulation works both ways right like if
you put if you put a if you put a jacket
on a snowman right it it's it's it
insulates the heat in it nice like they
actually they actually say to preserve
body heat like in like super cold
temperatures when you sleep it's
actually better to sleep naked than to
wear something
i just i just watched like worse i just
think that you know it's you meant to
sleep naked i just thought that was what
you're supposed to do where'd you get
this idea from [ __ ]
how god intended
like you know
oh god sleeps naked why why wear clothes
then which seems like a lot more effort
to be wearing clothes to bed like why
are you complicating it effort yeah just
go naked it's how hard is it to put a
shirt on for you i just think why are
you adding shirts into an equation that
doesn't need it you know
why why why do you like so then okay
question then yeah why need blankets
it's a question then right why not just
sleep on a slab serious question okay so
then when you start you know you start
doing the business you know you just
throw the shirt off yeah yeah that just
seems like a lot of work i'm always i'm
always ready it's two seconds
when you jack off do you wear a shirt
depends where i am
it's never really an part of the
equation of jacking off i'm just like do
i have my shirt on i feel like i'm like
the michelin man when i'm jacking off
wearing a shirt i feel like i'm like
constricted i'm like [ __ ] hell like
get the [ __ ] off
do you [ __ ] bulk up when you've been
have you never done the business with a
shirt on i have i don't like it it feels
like i'm i'm like i'm in some kind of
like constriction
i don't like it at all don't like it no
i feel strange i don't mind it no
sometimes you need to like you know
sometimes it's not the reason why you
know in porn they don't take they take
the [ __ ] off you know it's because you
want to get like well that's because
they're on [ __ ] camera mate yeah but
are you on camera i might be
i don't know what i
also it's like you know when you're
pooping sometimes you have to take your
shirt off yeah yeah yeah but that's more
of just like the same kind of energy
well that's the thing it's like because
it's intense i'll take it no no not
every poop needs to say you need to take
a shower i prefer if you speak for
yourself you know when you wake up i you
know when you wake up right and you've
the first poop do you take the shirt off
when you do it you just right no i keep
it on the poop like the shirt taking off
poops are for the poops that like fight
back yeah
like that
it's it's when like you need to like
like you you need that extra push
those are the poops that are like no i'm
staying here
the ones in the morning are kind of just
like all right it was a good night
generally prefer to just take it off
when i prove anyway why not not like
during the day if i'm like out in like
a public restroom
goes for a proof and just like he'd like
to takes off like the jojo's suit and i
took it over and takes off the tie takes
off the shirt and i'd still poop faster
than gone
i don't know it's just like a placebo
right it's like i just feel more
comfortable wearing a shirt to bed i
don't know what it is i think you've
you've nerfed yourself
in what way have we nerfed ourselves
i feel like you've nerfed yourself no
because i can i can poop without any
requirements you know what it also is it
doesn't sound like that because it
sounds like a requirement is that you
need to take a shirt off
you need to have nothing
that's that's literally a requirement we
don't i can sleep naked i just prefer to
have a shower if you're stranded without
a shirt then i'll sleep with my show
he's he's a wrestler he'll be
complaining
he's a reason as well though because
like i've actually experienced this
where like i in the middle of the night
we're in japan right earthquakes right
that happen all the [ __ ] time right
if there's a massive earthquake in the
middle of the night i don't want to be
that weirdo running out of my house but
[ __ ] naked
you have time to grab your clothes well
then why don't you just wear the shirt
at that point then i'm not if you have
the time to wear a shirt
ready for combat situations every
[ __ ] night i haven't got a draw full
of passports ready to go because i need
to be deported you know i this t-shirt
is on the floor this one extra second of
putting on the t-shirt which i can do on
the way to the elevator or some [ __ ] you
know i don't need to wait an element
it's an earthquake
i'm not walking downstairs i just have
this like mental image of just like if
if an earthquake happens when conor is
either sleeping or on the toilet it's
just gonna be that scene from borat all
over again
connor just like you emerges
if i'm [ __ ] in the middle of an
earthquake i'm taking my chances i'm
gonna carry on doing what i'm doing i'm
not
why would i run out i'm i feel like
running out is just a stupid idea just
stay in your house maybe yeah if you die
[Music]
no it is it is a very specific situation
of course like
i mean because when i when i was you
know when we uh evacuated in uh l.a i
felt like we did not need to evacuate i
felt like we should have just stayed in
our room i don't know what the
recommended guideline is but i'm pretty
sure running down to the bottom floor is
not the right idea i'm not using the
elevator yeah you can't run all the way
down yeah
i'll be around like 51 stories i would
say not using the elevator during an
earthquake it's probably like at the top
of like yeah i just had [ __ ] to do after
it so i really wanted to get down fast
so i was
this chick-fil-a nuggets weren't gonna
eat themselves as well and also i the
moment that i was immediately put off
going down the stairs was when we ran
past the american family and that guy
was acting like we were in like a
hollywood movie and we had like he had
like three kids and he was like
kids stay with me stay with your daddy
we got to go down together as a team
hold hands and i was like i'm like i'm
not i'm not being in this guy's movie
i'm going to do my own thing i'm i don't
want to be part of this that's that's
when i decided
that
like it was a pretty tense situation but
the moment i heard that
i was just like the earthquake had ended
you know it was like whatever i was not
really scared anymore the building was
still shaking but i was like whatever
it's not a big deal the building's built
for it yeah the building's built
different yeah through the standards to
withstand those so i was pretty
confident that we were going to be fine
yeah so i was like whatever i think i
i'll take the elevator
i didn't i realized that don't take
emergency advice from no no
i'm not i'm not recommending it i just
i'm lazy he just does it anyway i was
just you know i was i felt confident
enough that i was going to be fine
and if i died you know sure i can have
my darwin award in peace uh because i'm
dead so
i
a tangential sense where you just like
willingly put your life in danger just
for a bit of confusion i don't feel like
it was in danger because i didn't feel
that way because like living living in
thailand this is going a complete
tangent every time you get in the car
no no no no no
no no that's that's not a risk that's
not risking your life okay bangkok is
the only place i've lived in where
people willingly lift uh risk their
lives in the daily by taking a modus
aqua type motor motorcycle taxi like
daily in like some of the most dangerous
roads in the world just to save yourself
30 minutes of traffic right right and we
do that on the daily and i do that on a
daily i'm just like that's weird when
you think about it i i can't really
describe why i just wanted to take the
elevator but i think i just realized i
was like i could either walk down 70
floors of stairs or i could just risk it
and take the elevator and i think at
that point in time to me taking 70
flight of stairs was not worth my life
well i mean i can't i can't argue
against that because i also went in the
elevator
i think it was one of those things like
good idea connor it was like connor's
going in the elevator or if he's stupid
enough to risk his life i guess i feel
confident enough where yeah oh i'll go
in with it i can blame connor if i die
yeah exactly i don't know i know that i
shouldn't do it but i did so i mean we
ended up not going down anyway yeah so
what ended up happening was cosmic
justice is that the elevator to get down
you had to go up to the 70th floor yeah
the lobby to then get down and when we
got to the 70th floor uh they stopped
all the elevators yeah so basically we
went down about 35 stairs for nothing
yeah i was basically just instant karma
yeah
honestly right there and then we waited
10 minutes and the elevators started
working and then there was no problems
and i was very glad that i did yeah i
literally looked back at like what the
[ __ ] i mean mommy was like went down 75
the stairs turned around was like but
you know i you know when when stuff like
that happens i feel like i don't want to
be that guy who's panicking and running
around like all these people you know
that's the last thing to do i just feel
like this is gonna be sheep
this is this is wake up sheeple this is
how you're inviting a shitty situation
to happen you know um
you know and i also don't want to try my
chances on on the road uh you know
because when you leave the hotel you're
just facing the road yeah i don't want
to try my chances with stuff falling or
people driving on everything earthquake
i was pretty content that my room was
fine i was like well that's the thing is
like in some situations it's actually
more dangerous to go on the road because
in the case of japan we have so much
like electrical wiring yeah on the roads
that if those fall and snap they can
easily electrocute you [ __ ] you know
uh traffic signs can come down hurt you
yeah well i feel like the safest place
is just to probably be on the ground
floor yes
i don't know you get way more uh like
earthquake vibrations on the first floor
yeah yeah the best thing the higher up
the building the less you get like you
just get swaying if you're up top yeah
and when you're down below you get the
[ __ ] violent shaking yeah the best
thing to do is to just go out into like
a really really good market i
i feel like this is a point in my life
where i'm just like i don't know if i
should uh listen to this well advice
well because they're really
buildings are built on like rolling
mechanics yeah uh so when the building
you you [ __ ] experienced it what do
you mean the hotel we stayed in yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's built on rollers so
when the earthquake happens it starts
rolling yeah but on like the ground
floor
sometimes you literally don't even feel
the earthquake no because there's no
there's no swaying or anything like that
no because you're getting like the
actual [ __ ] earth shaking
that's that's that's not what it feels
like on the ground floor yeah it does
you did an earthquake on the ground
floor right yeah it feels very violently
shaking yeah but it's kind of the same
as being on the building i i when i
experienced both in japan i definitely
preferred in in la when the building was
just swaying
i was literally on the street and
sometimes i didn't even notice that
there was an earthquake when people were
yeah yeah yeah
because like
there was there's no there's nothing to
like how can i put this there's nothing
to put your perspective in that you're
in an earthquake you just feel like the
floor is big wobbly the floor doesn't
the floor doesn't move it shakes it does
[ __ ] it shakes it shakes but a lot of
the times you can't actually see it
moving until you look at something yeah
there's there's there's nothing to like
ground your perspective whereas if
you're in a building you can see other
buildings doing this yeah yeah exactly
like i don't really know most of the
times i don't even realize i'm in an
earthquake until i have something to
like ground that perspective right
sometimes i'm just sometimes
like living in japan sometimes i just
get up get a head rush i'm like oh was
that enough
like like you ever get there
there's so many earthquakes but like
you know when you're getting an
earthquake because you should be like
just [ __ ]
i'm like
my mom has the story of when she was in
school she was like running along the
tracks at school and like you know when
you're running like your entire world is
doing this yeah so she was running and
she was looking at the school building
and then she stopped and the building
just kept doing this and she realized
she was in an earthquake
and she didn't realize until she stopped
because to her perspective it's already
going up and down right yeah but then
it's it's i think again it's that like
perspective of being like that's not
moving the way it's intended to but also
i i don't you know the shake the swaying
and all that stuff i don't really give a
[ __ ] as long as like you know the
building isn't falling down yeah and i i
just want my stuff to break well yeah
that's that's that's the biggest thing
it's just like [ __ ] falling down isn't
it yeah that's why whenever there was an
earthquake i would just rush to my like
camera gear i'm like
hold my shoulders sick
jojo figures please
those are the real casualties and
earthquakes i had those like 400 500
jojo figures that were like very finely
balanced yeah that were like balanced
the weight was like like this so the
center of gravity was very worrying yeah
and during earthquakes i immediately had
to just like go to them if i was there
and during that we had we had one pretty
big earthquake and i was surprised
because my figures just stayed well i
mean the same was under the studio as
well yours didn't yeah it's weird
because the figures the the figures that
we that had uh fallen looked like pretty
normal figures but the one that i really
expected break didn't move at all well i
mean it's the same here as well like at
the old trafford i expected like rohan
to just be over all of these like
knocked over but the only casualty we
had was [ __ ] mike [ __ ] mic
every time i'm not at my house there's
an earthquake in japan i just assume my
house is going to be demolished when i'm
back i'm like everything's [ __ ] i have
to rebuild my whole life it's all ruined
do you guys have like the
anti-earthquake proof stuff in like your
cabinets you probably should do that it
really does make a difference that's it
yeah what is it so basically like oh i
mean there's lots of different
variations of it but i need it for most
stuff though i feel like it's for very
specific things um i we put it on most
stuff like most of the big stuff so like
if you have like uh figuring cabinets or
like bookshelves this is like little
kind of like they look like little
rubber door stops yeah i know oh no you
put them underneath and it completely
stops the shaking from happening yeah i
wanted to get the figures to stop
shaking yeah so i have i have them under
like all of my bookshelves and figuring
cabinets and stuff like that and you
know i've seen them move in an
earthquake that that [ __ ] doesn't budge
so that's really good and also like
there's also these like little like
sticky pads kind of thing that you can
put on like some like figurines and
stuff like that it's just weird that you
have to like live in the country and you
just worry about like just like like
insta death just happening like in the
uk like nothing kills people to death
but it's not exactly insta-death oh just
worry well i mean it might be
if you're in the wrong situation yeah
yeah yeah
i mean i suppose like i've we've been
lucky enough to never have been in a bad
earthquake
i don't like like i i feel like
don't [ __ ] say
well they've been predicting the mega
quake for like a few years now in tokyo
yeah yeah yeah yeah where there's a
bound to be some kind of like tokyo
eight or nine yeah yeah [ __ ]
earthquake in tokyo and i'm not i hope
to god it happens in the next three
weeks i'm not here
jesus christ i bet you'll wish you were
on the ground floor then connor yeah
that's all i'll say well i felt like the
shaking was very violent i used to live
on the like a fourth or fifth floor and
it used to shake really weirdly i didn't
like it i felt like it was just high
enough up where i got really [ __ ]
violent shirts yeah yeah i got i was on
the eighth floor and i think with the
the biggest earthquake we were in which
was long earthquake earthquake
earthquake the biggest earthquake we
were in which was the one where the fig
my figures fell over uh i wasn't the
toilet at the time but like that's the
safest room to be in yeah i was in the
math one time as well but that
earthquake just lasted for so [ __ ]
long it felt like it lasted like two
minutes or something at least yeah yeah
going wrong yeah because it just it just
started and like at which point because
you have to make this mental judgment of
at which point do i start giving a [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
because most of the time it's a little
because it happens so often it happens
so often so i'm just like oh is this the
one i should start carrying yeah it's
like it's not stopping should i start
caring now but also what are you gonna
do if you give a [ __ ] like what am i
gonna do just be like oh [ __ ] i'm
worried well you have to like evacuate
to your nearest evacuation point which
everyone should know when you move
nowhere is this [ __ ] no no
we got you gotta get under the door
frame right if it's door frame but also
like if it gets really bad then there's
like in your local town there's usually
like evacuation points normally if like
your water and [ __ ] turns off and all
that is right um no in a lot of
situations it's like earthquakes and
floods and stuff like that yeah but why
why would you leave your house in an
earthquake if it's like that's surely if
it's like unstable no well i mean what
if the building's on it's usually in the
case of like you know if the earthquake
is really powerful that your water stops
all your electricity stops your gas
that's what i thought right it was to
get like supplies and shelter yeah
because if the winter if it's really
[ __ ] cold and you know your
electricity turns off and then you kind
of screw which i'm kind of [ __ ]
because like i am not stocked up on any
kind of emergency or disaster yeah we
recently like restocked ourselves like
all over the front
it's been meaningful yeah
two years now we need to do that oh yeah
i'll get around to it
remember like uh for journey across
japan we went to like sakurajima which
is that like island uh or volcano
yeah in kakashima and i remember like
two weeks after we left there it [ __ ]
erupted
and it's like and that entitled it was
like pretty big as well and it made me
realize i was like oh yeah earthquakes
are like the least of my worries because
japan is like [ __ ] volcanic area
there's like so many active like food
malfuji's [ __ ] active volcano is it
yeah it is
it is it's a and it's it's an active
volcano and it last erupted i think
about 250 years ago and they're
expecting it 250 years ago yeah in like
the edo period it last erupted oh and
then they're expecting it to erupt like
soon sick so i'm like
sick
they actually did a simulation if it
erupts completely it actually reaches
all the way to uh uh
oh sure it's still that far yeah wow
it's kind of like a yellow stone right
in america that's like one of the
biggest active super volcanoes in the
world and if that erupts then it's just
like kind of like the end of
civilization for like a lot of people
yeah exactly yeah because a lot of the
waters at yellowstone are like boiling
hot like the lakes yeah yeah exactly
yeah some horrifying stories people
jumping in the water
thinking that they can swim in it oh and
it's boiling
that's uh that's probably i don't know
when it's so bad when do i leave my
house i i don't know that does is it
like a hard guide on what i mean i mean
i'm pretty sure you'll know when you're
no yeah you know what i mean like when
it gets to the point where it's like oh
i can't be here for a multitude of
reasons then it's time yeah yeah the
ones that i'm really scared of the
earthquakes in japan but the ones that
do kind of make me uncomfortable is when
it starts small and it just keeps
getting bigger yeah and then you're like
when will it stop will it keep
escalating yeah because when it starts
off big and it doesn't get any worse i'm
like okay okay cool it's little it's the
long ones for me though yeah right where
it starts you like shakes
shakes shakes and you're like please
okay please please stop yeah
when is this going to peak yeah
this is the peak no it's not peaking yet
i just feel like it's the british in me
where you just don't take any kind of
like natural disaster seriously i'm just
like come on
all right stop this now come on got
enough of this i'm pretty sure it's a
natural disaster come on there's no
natural disasters in the world
so you guys don't have like any natural
disasters no there's some flooding but
very light it's not right right
yeah we have flooding here like i i like
i i hear i hear like of like uh like uh
like a weather warning in japan i'm just
like what the [ __ ] the weather warning
how come whether my phone has been on
permanent weather warning since i've
moved here yeah but i i'd love to
imagine the first time like a british
person like went abroad right in like
1600s and they're like
there's an earthquake like what the [ __ ]
was that what the [ __ ] was that and
they're like yeah that happens all the
time what do you mean that happens all
the time the earth just moves the earth
just moves and you're all okay with this
you haven't asked management what's
going on it's all living
and then like yeah yeah yeah and
sometimes the the mountain explodes the
mountain explodes
and
[Applause]
the mountain explodes we get these
things called typhoons yeah they're like
what do you mean lava that's hell
there's hell coming out that's we've
only seen that in the books this doesn't
happen what is this is nonsense there's
twenty thousand leagues and you accept
this this is okay with you
it's like what is a typhoon it's just a
bit of wind in it bit of wind never
hurts anyone just a bit of rain we get
that all the time
it's bit of rain and wind what do you
mean nature destroyed your house and did
you get a refund
what is all this what is a tsunami it's
just a wave
yeah when we think about it we japan
really is like world number one when it
comes to like the variety of [ __ ]
things that can kill you in nature yeah
we really do have everything because i
remember before like i moved out of
england you'd hear about these disasters
that happened all the way in the other
side of the world
right it's like like the japan tsunami
which is like an awful tragedy that
happens and you just didn't it didn't it
never quite
sank in yeah that felt really like how
how bad it was like i remember just
before we moved to japan where like you
guys were having like super bad thai few
and typhoons and like the
the videos that came out just look super
bad and yeah just like
i i it still doesn't sink into me that
it's just this bad here in japan yeah as
a british person because i've just never
experienced it
irl in real life like it's never just
happened right in front of me it really
it really is like completely different
like you could watch like hundreds of
videos on it and the one that you've
actually experienced in real life is
like unlike anything you would ever
imagine it is like it's like those
typhoons look bad it's a hundred times
worse in real life watching like
earthquakes from like the 2011
earthquake uh it's like really [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] terrifying yeah just seeing
like people just everything's shaking
super violently i'm like oh gosh and
just like the water level rising and
[ __ ] is like terrifying that happened 10
years ago man
it's weird yeah time flies 2011. holy
[ __ ] i was still in university
i would gladly take
volcanoes if we can get onsens
stick a volcano somewhere in wales i
will have an onsen
would onsen culture work in the uk
if we had volcanoes yeah you sure yeah i
think so i wouldn't
they serve alcohol you just want you
just want it to work i'll make it work
we'll serve beer not not if people have
to get naked yeah in front of each other
i i think you you underestimate how i
think that culture is like just wouldn't
work in the uk it would not work if you
teach them from a young age listen
maybe okay but like being naked is
normal yeah you could teach a group of
people cannibalism from a young age and
they'll think it's all right
yeah we're not talking about we're not
talking about if youtube if
like if the entire history of the uk had
changed to introduce his culture from
the beginning because then they'd just
be [ __ ] japan
if you gave them a free beer at the end
of it like you go and make it with your
boys you get a free beer they do it you
sure 100
i i doubt if i went up to a guy from the
uk like born and bred never left the
country and i said i'll give you a beer
if you get in this bath with this other
dude naked when you say it like that
that sounds way worse because that's
what a nonsense because they're probably
imagining some tight traditional bath
where they're like dicks are touching
and they're like oh god oh oh i'm so
scared of people i mean there are our
own senses
well yeah but not really public ones
though oh well i mean we've been in one
have we yeah remember yeah
we've been pretty close together at the
end of the cycling yeah yeah we went in
that really really tight onsen literally
it was like me you joey and chris and
like our legs were definitely touching
yeah
i don't remember this
that just shows how like used to you
it's just like nothing to you yeah just
think you know because i'm sure someone
who's not used to that type of culture
would find that true
especially a lot of brits you know
imagine being scared of a penis though i
just couldn't imagine it like i mean
you'd be surprised
like not not even like not even being
scared of penises but like just like the
social boundary of seeing your mates
penis yeah or seeing it's like seeing
someone close to you and just knowing
what they look like naked i mean i'm
totally fine with it now yeah but that's
that's because i've done it so that's
the thing yeah it's like it's that one
thing of just like getting to that point
and once you're over it then you're over
it right but i think it's for a lot of
people it stops at getting to that point
yeah maybe maybe in the uk if it's in
the uk i would think it's weird which is
why for me it's like it's such a shame
because when people from overseas come
to japan for the first time and they're
like i want to know everything about the
culture you know like what are some like
really unique japanese things and of
course the first thing i think of is
onsens right yeah but
immediately i always hesitate being like
all right get this
you're about to see my dick
but in like a cool way
it's like a nice cyberpunk music when
you said that like in like a nice
relaxing way like we're in a bath
together and yes we're naked but it's
not weird it's not weird trust me and
we're with other random people as well
but it's not weird you know that's the
first thing i tell people now it's just
like you want to come to japan you want
me to take you around we're going to an
onsen yeah all right well i think is
that out the way yeah i think it you
know if someone's willing to go to the
onsen with you they're probably up for
anything yeah everything japanese
culture yeah i feel like if you if you
can't trial by fire you can't put your
own uh cultural differences aside
to participate in another culture then
uh i don't think you're i agree and and
and yeah again like that's what i kind
of use as a gauge of like cultural
understanding for that person it's like
if they can get over this then you'll be
fine i'm very open to some things but
there are some things where i've seen in
like you know when they had like what
was it there's a tv show called like
tribes in the uk there's just a dude who
went around tribes and like the amazon
or something and there was one thing
that he did that i was like okay i don't
think i'd do that and it was like it's
like a
penis inverting ceremony or something
oh you've seen the video with the guy
like faint yeah and i was like yeah you
know what i thought i was up for a lot
but i think that's that's where i'm good
yeah yeah i've seen the one where they
have to like wear that glove of just
like bullet ants yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
i'm just like why would anyone want to
do this because
if i was you know you gave me enough
beers maybe i'd do the answering but
let's go
but the the
it's the video of that guy when the guy
like the tribal chief does it to him and
he faints immediately yeah oh god it
sounded terrible yeah just just here i
think there are many penises like going
ah yeah
yeah i'm pretty much up for anything
that doesn't involve like destroying my
body or pain or yeah stuff like that i'm
pretty much down for anything yeah i'm
usually down for anything when it comes
to like you know especially when it
comes to things like food and yeah which
is why i hate when people lie to me
about their like make a joke they're
like yeah our culture we do this and
then they just lied to me and i didn't
have to put my penis in public i'm
kidding
this why i trust my friends when i go
somewhere new and they're like this is
what we do here i'm like i trust you
that sounds weird but i trust you please
don't [ __ ] me like god could be like
yeah so in thailand we uh get our dicks
out in restaurants and swing them around
all right well okay
do it i know he is as well that's the
word i'm just waiting for the perfect
opportunity to i'm gonna i'm gonna do
because i've only got one chance to do
it too like do it exactly completely
lose that trust in australia like you
have to snort all your alcohol be like
okay
yeah you have to drink alcohol through
your eyes
i think
australians do do yeah we do do that
it's called a suicide shot yeah i'm
pretty sure used to have like a lot of
shows in the uk that would like cover
like binge drinking and like clubbing i
don't know why we had tv shows about
this okay yeah and there'd be this one
show and this is where i first
discovered that people did vodka shots
through their eyeball yeah yeah and it
was weird and they would do it and
they'd be like they'd ask them the
interview would ask them what'd you do
he's like because i just get drunk so
fast and i'm like is drinking like not
fast enough it's pretty fast it's pretty
damn instant
it's pretty [ __ ] and then it just
immediately cut to a doctor who is like
yeah well actually you know in certain
any kind of alcohol in your eye is
extremely dangerous and can remove the
lipid layer of uh yeah can permanently
damage and possibly blind you yeah i was
like oh you know i don't need a [ __ ]
professional doctor telling me that like
it should be common sense yeah it's like
it's like sticking a splinter in your
butt it's like i didn't need a doctor to
tell me that didn't need to go there
it's weird man
it's so strange because i feel like in
the uk with partying and all that
there's so many stuff that you just do
it because everyone else tells you yeah
yeah
yeah
i just always sat there thinking like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah it's it's
definitely like you especially in
university where just gosh just like the
the
idea of doing a dirty shot now just like
makes me makes me feel what is a dirty
shot explain to the viewer's gun and mix
i forgot yeah i don't know what it is
either or a dirty pine you just like you
play probably most of the time it's
[ __ ] ring of fire right right
which
and then you have this pint glass in the
middle where whenever you draw a certain
card you have to fill it up with
whatever alcohol i feel something
whatever alcohol that person is drinking
and sometimes if you're in like an ultra
hardcore party then you fill up with
like other [ __ ] that you would never put
in a [ __ ] drink like like [ __ ] like
washing up liquid or stuff like that
yeah they would do it or like tabasco
sauce or yeah like fernando sauce we had
a rule in ours where whoever lost they
had to leave the room for 30 seconds and
anything in the kitchen could be put in
the drink yeah people people would put
like pepper grains washing up liquid and
like they would drink it i understand
pepper grains are like tabasco but
washing up liquid yeah because you would
immediately throw it up there's no yeah
i've actually done it before when i was
17. you [ __ ] idiot yeah you're
[ __ ] disappointed
lucky for some reason during my whole
time at university when i played this
game i never got it yeah i would have
refused i mean we played that game but
we you know made it stuff that you could
actually drink yeah it's really good
that's uh that's the civilization also i
had food poisoning yesterday and i feel
dreadful and hearing this makes you feel
even more dreadful
why did you get food poisoning connor i
ate a bad sausage i had a bad sausage i
ordered two sausages i cut one up and uh
it was very very pink on the inside
that's a bad sign i thought no i'm not
eating that one but i cut the other one
and it looked okay
what kind of sausage was it was it like
italian sausage [ __ ] terrible
narrator and it was not okay
you are a cornering food poisoning yeah
you are so susceptible to it i think
since you've been in japan you've had
food poisoning like at least three or
four times
yeah that was the worst one you had food
poisoning for like a week i was [ __ ]
and vomiting for like a week straight it
was terrible
oh
god i think i'm only about food
poisoning once in japan because they
serve so much raw [ __ ] yeah yeah like
you know they serve raw chicken here you
know and they say like oh there's no
salmon there is salmonella there's just
way less of it right there's
you're less you're just less likely to
get it doesn't mean you can't get you
know i'm not being funny but you should
not eat raw chicken like i don't care if
japan is like yeah it's safe no i've had
i've had it before yeah but it's it's
not it's not even that good it's not
that good and you are rolling a dice
yeah you you can eat it but you are
rolling well i i had raw chicken at uh
an izakaya that's specialized in raw
chicken because there's a lot of stuff
there's a lot of izakayas that just like
give it i don't like it
it's a cultural thing right where people
are just like this is safe this is safe
and i'm just like is it though is it is
it safe it's like you you are eating it
and there is a risk there is still of
course there's a risk but it's you know
you are unlikely to get food poisoning
from eating the raw chicken but there is
still a chance you can still get it
especially if your stomach is way more
than other foods you know right yeah but
i mean i mean a lot of things especially
in i feel like in asia which just has a
lot of a lot less standards when it
comes to say the health and safety of
the food you surf i feel like i feel
like i feel like even like japan
compared to the rest of asia has really
really good food standards yeah uh
compared to [ __ ] southeast asia oh
yeah oh my god
compared to the uk it's like japan that
doesn't batter knife it's like pinkish
and i'm like oh yeah my chicken's pink
in the middle i'm like oh god
yeah
i mean yeah the only time i got food
poisoning was when i went to the
philippines for the first time and uh
you know of all things i could have got
food poisoning from it wasn't the duck
fetus it wasn't even the water it was a
[ __ ] mango shake
oh yeah i ate a [ __ ] mango straight
off the [ __ ] like like street vendor
and that's what gave me food poisoning
i'm like cool
yeah amazing it was a fantastic shake
but man i was [ __ ] like i was
pissing out my ass for about two days
it was horrible i think i think the
worst food poisoning i've ever got was
uh from china actually when i was still
living there and you know when when you
when you live in china like the food the
food there is [ __ ] great especially
like the street food
but it's just like trying trying to
pinpoint where you got food poisoning
there
is uh like a needle in a hay it's kind
of like a needle and a haystack like
you're just just like
where did the which one of these food
stands did like get food poisoning from
it could be any one of them
could be like a culmination of all of
them together
it was like so bad that i almost had to
go to the hospital because i remember it
was it was like new year's eve for like
one of the years i can't remember which
year exact year it was but i remember
it was i was sitting on the toilet and i
needed to throw up at the same time that
i was shooting
and
those are the worst
you laughed but like it was a traumatic
what were you just alternating
i i was i was i was like you have to
like
i was trying to like i was trying to
like keep it in but that one time one
time i literally like i literally could
not like hold either one so i literally
like need this like
well i was sitting on the toilet and i
needed to like try to like aim i can't
listen to this it's it's awful i don't
want to get too graphic um i've done
that before but it's it's like it was
the most awful food poisoning experience
i've ever had you know um it's kind of
like a scene out of south park where
i know which one
and
yeah
and then uh and then pukes up and then
has a nose lead at the same time
it was like that was that was my
experience
yeah say what you will about fast food
chains i've never gotten food poisoning
for a fast food chain i've never gotten
food poisoning from like you mean like
like junk food yeah like mcdonald's
whatever i've never i've ever
gotten i've never gone food poisoning
from it personally but i have gotten
very sick yeah like i felt bad just felt
like i've never had to throw up after
eating like kfc or
something i don't know about america
i've seen some really ghastly ones in
america
in the uk and japan i've had nothing but
good experiences no japan is really good
with fast food i think like the few
times that i've had mcdonald's in
america i was like i feel like i really
want to throw off i feel so i really
want to throw this up yeah it's horrible
i don't know how they make burgers taste
so bad at mcdonald's in america they
don't know what they do
i don't know man because
it scores mcdonald's just makes enough
enough money like worldwide yeah and in
america there's just so much better
like
so much better burgers right though
there's a more higher end but yeah yeah
there's way more competition in america
i feel uh i feel like in america
mcdonald's lives off the reputation of
howard
america the rest of the world right yeah
this episode is sponsored by boxing oxu
is a monthly snack box subscription
service that delivers original
assortments of premium japanese snacks
and tea pairings boxes not just a
premium snack subscription service but a
way of getting to know the japanese
culture first-time boxing customers will
receive the season of japan box so they
can get a taste of the snacks per season
and shipping to the us is free get out
of here it's almost autumn here in japan
and you know what that means boys
the autumn box is here no that's right
it's right here look are you talking
about fall
americans
in japan people love to observe the
changing of the leaves by going on an
autumn leaf hunt and snacking on manju
they also attend akimatsuri or the fall
festivals to commemorate a great harvest
what have we got in there connor we have
some milk manju where is that gamers
manju is a historic steam japanese suite
created by wrapping ingredients like
bean paste and a kneaded wheat shell
this treat is milk flavored for a creamy
and sweet tasting experience delicious
and we also have kyoto matcha waffle
sandwiches crunchy and matcha flavored
an amazing collaboration of experiences
this actually looks really good actually
yeah damn and more oh god i think you
forgot about the satoshi heart shaped
lemon mini pies as well oh my god is
that those over there
right here
those are those shaped pies look at
these and there is tons more in the box
this box is stacked gentlemen and you
can get all of these lovely snacks and
more for halloween with the code trash
taste 10. link is in the description to
get tempted off your boxu subscription
thank you boxy for sponsoring us today
back to the episode speaking of
traveling and stuff uh we're going this
is the last podcast before we head back
to the uk yeah so it's you're not going
to see a break but we're going to have
about like a six seven weeks yeah like a
month and a half break basically yeah
yeah six week break which is the longest
break we've ever taken
i want to see people who are like
binging trash taste like watching this
episode and then going to the next me
like what the [ __ ] happened i wonder if
there's any difference like what if i
just get a scar like a really cool scarf
yeah you just come back and you're just
like completely bald
like just got an eye patch on or
something like that
no it's been really with me for the past
few weeks uh because i've been living
alone i guess for
like the past two three weeks sydney
went back to yeah sydney's down seems
back in america and i think this is like
the longest we've been apart for like
time huh
it's so
weird not having a partner home and it's
just one the home feels so empty like my
god like if it wasn't for corona
lockdown i would want to meet so many
people because i'm just like i i i need
to uh do something
you need someone to talk to you i i need
someone to talk to i need someone to
fill in the gap of like [ __ ] having
no one in your house i didn't i've
forgotten what that felt like right
i forgot when i feel that i
yeah to me it's like i don't feel that
way yeah i i now see why you try to meet
up with as many people as you can
because if i was
if i was in your shoes i would do the
same because uh it's uh it's it's lonely
without having someone just there to
talk to you whenever i want to be alone
sometimes i really value being able to
just like do whatever i want no i like
my alone time too
i like it
i like my lone time as well and i feel i
feel like any healthy relationship you
have space to be uh have your alone time
but if you're feeling lonely you just
yours there's just someone there also
another thing is that uh the chores are
now like i have i'm in charge of all the
chores and i'm just like what is this
like this is gonna sound a bit
misogynistic right but like
in in my in my household i'm in charge
of the washing up okay and sydney is in
charge of uh of the uh
of the laundry right right and so i was
just used to only do the washing up and
having the woman doing the laundry right
why did you have to say it like that i
just wanted to sound as misogynistic
i just want to sound as misogynistic as
i can because now i am there's no one to
do the laundry and i'm just like woman
where is my laundry done and i just
realized i have to do it myself now
i just like to imagine like i just like
slowly enter god's house and from across
the house i just hear woman
i need a fresh pair of underwear you
really got done dirty because laundry is
like the easiest of the house yeah i'm
the one that does laundry in our house
yeah i think washing up the dishes is
far more painful i i hate washing up the
dishes and how did you why did you agree
to that because i also hate doing the
laundry as well i just need to know i
like the laundry laundry nice
fresh sheets
i mean like now that we've bought like a
washing machine with a built-in dryer
all i have to do is just like [ __ ]
take it out and fold it up but i like
the process of folding up washing i
don't know why i hate that it's just
it's it's it's meditative it's so
unoptimized i just i just like because
the thing is the thing about the laundry
thing the thing about the laundry is
that like at least with washing up it's
just a one activity thing you get it
over with with laundry you have to put
it in and then you have to remember that
you put the laundry in and sometimes i'm
such a forgetful [ __ ] that like you
forget hours after you afterwards that
you had laundry in the laundry machine
and then you you take it out and it
[ __ ] stinks yeah because you left it
in there for so long it's like wet so
then you have to re-laundry your [ __ ]
laundry but that's just sounds like are
you problems that is a me problem god i
hate like the laundry machines often
have this very loud thing called a
beeping yeah it goes
when it's done yeah but sometimes you
just do you might have heard it on your
microphone some saying the same thing
sometimes you're just doing [ __ ]
sometimes you're just like oh let me let
me just finish up this piece of work and
then i'll do the laundry and then you
just forget that you hear that again
that sounds like a you problem like
because i have because if i'm doing work
and then i hear from my laundry machine
going dude i'm like all right time to do
the [ __ ]
i don't know how hard it is not that
difficult yeah also i don't have to
worry about dishes anymore because we
have a dishwasher so i wish i wish i
wish that was i feel like i'm like a
caveman just
evolving i feel like discovering
civilization for the first time yeah i
mean like this is dishes i was used to
doing but like with laundry is this how
like is this how like men felt in the
60s you know like
because in our house i have to do the
the laundry and the dishes because
that's the one show that aki hates doing
so she does like the vacuuming and like
the cleaning up and stuff like that
because i i [ __ ] hate vacuuming the
house but uh i also hate vacuuming
imagine doing all of it yourself yeah
exactly wow well i had to do that when i
was living on my own
but like now it's like
but now i feel bad because
my two chores which is the laundry and
the dishes i just let the machine do it
so i literally just like press a button
i'm like done
and it's great
i wish i wish that was me yeah i have to
wash my dishes by hand and my laundry
doesn't have a dryer as well dude i'm
telling you man like when you're when
you like the dryers and laundry machines
i feel like they ruin the clothes i
don't like the dryer either really i
also hate having to put out the laundry
yeah i hate having to put out the
laundry because there's something good
about an old-fashioned natural drive it
just kind of gets to me it does it does
but the problem with that is that you
are at the mercy of the weather yeah
right because like what are you meant to
do in the winter time hanging inside
right the best the best well i just
hanging outside we're going about what
in the rain the rain well it's not
permanently raining in the winter yeah
but what if you have laundry that just
finished and it starts raining yeah oh
it's unfortunate but you can just hang
it up somewhere else yeah inside yeah so
basically what i just [ __ ] said like
you can do it outside it's not a big
deal you know no it is a big deal
because it's going to get dirty again
from the rain that's all right you can
wash it again it's even more clean see
that's that's what someone living on
their own would say yeah i know right
i would have said the same thing if i
was living alone because it's like oh
it's my clothes [ __ ] it who cares yeah
but you know i have to take care of
another person's clothes and she doesn't
quite like that
does aki get like no you have to do it
this way oh no it's more so it's not so
much archie's preference it's also just
[ __ ] common sense don't try and don't
try washing in the rain
out when it's raining because sometimes
you put it out then it starts raining
you forget that it's raining so you
didn't notice right away and it's a
little wet you're like i have to do it
again yeah
at that point that's just annoying right
because then you just
if i feel like leaving out in the rain i
have to rewatch it yeah because i mean
that washes out the good stuff about the
uh laundry right i'm simply one man i
cannot conquer nature i've accepted that
right so that's why i bought a washing
machine that has a really good dryer
you're trying to play god no no no no no
no because
here's the here's the thing right here's
the thing because
if if you dry your clothes in the dryer
then you're going to need to eye in your
shirts right yeah i i feel i feel like
if it's like naturally dried sometimes
if you get if you get out just fresh out
of the washing you're like you're like
uh what's
yeah i was trying to think of the
english word because i just knew the
thai word for it
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] whip the clothes
yeah and it dries naturally you just get
the creases out and it's like it's like
a nice sometimes a lot of times unless
you're wearing like a really expensive
shirt or something that needs to be
ironed like most of the time for like
natural t-shirts um you get you get the
creases out so that's why i've always
hated actually having to use the dryer
right well i get that but there's also
like uh we use like these like kind of
drying sheets that you like throw into
the washing machine after it's done that
creates less creases in the clothes
it's like a thing apparently i didn't
know aki found on amazon i was like
japan's [ __ ] game like this that
sometimes works sometimes doesn't yeah
church like yeah put this in your fridge
it'll make it smell like oranges and
then it like smells like orange like my
last washing machine supposedly had a
dryer inside of it and i spent it for
like three hours and i was like oh cool
it's just a little less damp than it was
before japan is fantastic the king
that's selling you [ __ ] that you think
you need that you don't actually need it
doesn't work exactly i just remember um
so do you guys have an issue of like
you're [ __ ] trash
really really [ __ ] thinking in the
summer yeah like no yeah but i do i
remember when i go to your house your
trash for some reason always smells
dreadful i don't know why because
doesn't smell that bad like the
burnables sometimes yeah because like we
don't cook often right so sometimes it's
just we just we have we have like a
little trash there but especially in the
summer sometimes it just like [ __ ]
decomposes yeah yeah yeah in the summer
all right and i'm [ __ ] long are you
leaving this there yeah do you not throw
it out every week uh no well there's
your problem
that's why you're not throwing it out
every week oh because it doesn't get
full every week yeah it doesn't matter
like you should throw it out how do you
as a couple get not get it full every
week i get it full every week yeah i get
it
yeah every week yeah i i get i get a
house full every week yeah we sometimes
have to go through like two bags we have
to go through like two bags of burnables
a week like i don't know we finish off
foods we i try to finish my food too
how are you feeling what are you what
does it feel for sometimes shot on
amazon comes in the box it's burnable
stuff you know and whatever like that's
cardboard no no no no like sometimes
they give material that's like not the
polystyrene and it's not bubble wrap
it's like the [ __ ] that's burnable yeah
and then like if you you know for
example like if you get ubereats for
example right yeah and like i get a lot
of ubereats yeah like the boxes and
stuff like that the food scraps that's
all burnable oh i feel very you washed
the boxes do you not washed wash your
hands on the box that was up material i
did not wash the box i just throw it all
in the bowl wow wow joey wait so what is
no no no because i don't push the box in
the burnables the burner balls is purely
just food waste well that's why it
stinks
where are you putting the other burner
balls yeah where are you putting all the
vinyls are there you know some some like
a lot of the food food scraps and also
you know like if you have like um
certain materials if it gets oily or if
it gets stuck yeah it's it's
yeah wait wait so so when you order a
pizza do you wash the pizza box when
it's done um like i it goes on with the
cardboard like no
no that's not you're supposed to put in
the burnables dude
no because most of the time if it comes
in like a plastic tray or plastic
whatever uh you can just wash it and
then put it in put it in the plastics
yeah so no no no
yeah plastics yeah a lot of the food
trays aren't like plastic they're not
plastic anymore they're like they're
like cardboard like yeah paper no no no
stuff most of it most of it is plastic
most like most of everything i get is
plastic most of the stuff i could start
referencing so like what happens right
is uh is unfortunately most of my burner
balls like pretty much nine percent of
my burning balls is like pure food waste
yeah and that just we don't have a lot
of food waste right right so it just
ends up that a lot of food like just
accumulates not a lot of food like a
little bit of food accumulates there and
because it's this in the summer it just
decomposes so quickly that's all the
more reason to take it out every week
even if it's not full i i have like a
small bag that's attached to like the
kitchen counter yeah and because i go
through so much tea and tea decomposes
very fast yeah yeah that's where all the
tea and all the small bits of food that
i don't eat right so that it's a tiny
plastic bag that i can tie up and take
out every week but
it doesn't smell yeah i think i think
it's not actually just the food it's
just because it's so humid as well that
just like you should definitely get the
like the humidity like condenses inside
the bag so like it it ends up that you
have like the garbage water in
at the bottom as well yeah yeah yeah
should definitely get through you can
throw out tiny bags you know that's loud
huh you can it doesn't have to be big
bags of trash yeah you can throw a
little you can throw a little like
combini bag levels of trash sometimes
you just forget like
that sounds like a you probably just
feel like consulting people on their
recycling no i mean what i was going to
say was so so obviously the trash ended
up smelling
at least like sometimes they throw it up
throw it out every week in the summer
but it's sometimes still just smelled
right i really don't like smelly trash
when i open the trash yeah yeah so we
had well in that in in my case if it
like if it you know i open up the trash
and it like really stinks like that
decomposing smell yeah i just double bag
it
so like i close up the first bag i get a
second bag and i wrap that up again and
then i only really do that if it's
written
yeah because what we did was we there
was like this there was this device from
uh daiso right i think it's by so or
like amazon already red flags
there was this device from begone that
uh was basically like like you know you
know that thing you put on the toilet to
make it smell nice when you whenever you
fly yeah yeah it was like the equivalent
of that but you put it on the bottom
of the lid of the garbage yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and completely solved the
issue our
our
our bin smelled like great it smelled it
smelled fresh japan is the only country
on earth that gives a [ __ ] what is yeah
yeah [ __ ] smells like it it smelled
fresh and i was like great this is this
is a [ __ ] amazing device oh my god
this has just saved me this has made my
kitchen like actually pleasant to be in
yeah until until about like a month in
when we needed to uh take out the trash
and uh we noticed that what there were a
lot of flies like i don't know how the
flies where the flies came from you
never know where they're from i didn't
know where the flies were yeah you had a
lot of flies i remember yeah and i was
like where were these where are these
flies coming from and how
how why are they gathering all around
the bin because this never happened
before right and so um and so sydney
cine opens the opens the lid and there's
there's like a few
we can see like literally like a few fly
eggs on the lid on the lid cover and i
was like what the [ __ ] how did this get
here and then
and then i i had to wash it right
obviously because sydney was scared of
it so i had to wash it and then
and then i was like okay i got to take
off the nice smelling thing take it off
and okay so that it's like it's like a
rectangle it's like a rectangle patch
and i took off the rectangle patch
and the entire patch was filled with
eggs i had like an entire patch of fly
eggs that were just covered because of
this one patch so this this nice
smelling patch this nice sunny smelling
patch
this nice smelling patch had just
attracted all the [ __ ] flies in the
vicinity i have no idea i have no
[ __ ] idea dinosaur you got to do
something about that [ __ ] i'm like i i
had to [ __ ] quarantine the place my
god
like the thing with the thing was like i
would throw the trash can out yes the
thing was like [ __ ] chernobyl like i
had to like like quiet to quarantine the
entire kitchen
that's so disgusting
yeah
yeah dude like i don't know what it is
like it doesn't matter if you have like
the cleanest kitchen in the world i
don't know where the [ __ ] these flies
are coming from they're just like it's
like it's like a re like the kitchen is
a respawn point for some of these
[ __ ] flies like there's just appear
out of thin air it's like i am here now
time to terrorize yeah this is like you
know you know in like a jinjito manga
where you turn the panel and you see
like the monster that was it when i like
shredded off that [ __ ] patch shut
oh my god to talk about something more
pleasant yeah
um go go back to laundry yeah like i
i've already like i'm
i remember when i moved it opened up my
laundry and there was flowers
i i remember moving out of my mom's
place i was just like laundry all you
need to put is a bit of detergent there
and laundry is done my god i didn't know
how [ __ ] opie fabric softener was
well yeah
until i started doing my own laundry
like like not many people talk about it
but my god fabric soft no it's one of
the it's it's a life hack that actually
works
i literally do like the two shots of
vodka meme with my with my two shots of
fabric softener
honestly i i go through detergents so
slowly like one cup of vodka and it's
like the whole [ __ ] jug i put in
i know i know it's bad for your clothes
but i don't give a [ __ ] it's so comfy
yeah i put a tiny amount in and it works
because like i feel like with with
clothes and especially with uh
with your bed covers like i can't i
don't know how people sleep without
not putting fabric softener on their bed
covers sheets and stuff
yeah sure i want to be in that maximum
comfort man damn i want to be embraced
you want to be embraced
it's like a light hug from your mom you
don't want to sleep naked exactly you
know you don't want to throw my nut sack
to feel the fabric softness all my
nutsacks to be embraced
by my sheets
on the gods liquid known as fabric
softener
i can't wait
it's gonna be weird though we're coming
back yeah yeah yeah are you guys uh
excited yeah of course i mean he's not
excited for all the quarantine yeah but
i mean it's been what like a full almost
two years now right since you guys were
in the uk last year um i haven't seen
anyone
yet yeah sweet i've never gone two years
out seeing my family
yeah it is a massive pain in the ass to
travel right now yeah yeah i i like just
seeing the all the paperwork you guys
have to do
jesus christ yeah like getting out the
country seems pretty simple and easy
it's getting back in the country that is
uh that sounds uh we're gonna we're
gonna save our experiences for when we
actually come back from from third-hand
experiences
um
actually sounds like a prison camp yeah
like that i'm like i'm not joking like
my mate who uh went out went back in he
like the experience he told me sounded
like a prison camp and then he sent me
an article of some of the olympic uh
olympic athletes that had to come in the
country and had to quarantine yeah and
they literally also said that prison
camps were probably like they were
probably would probably be better
treated in prison camps than they were
in like the quarantine hotels that they
were already yikes um so i'm gonna read
a lot of manga yeah yeah just stock up
on all the manga man like dude you can
finally catch up on one piece
yeah yeah while you're in quarantine
just really just read one piece man yeah
yeah do it do it i don't gain too much
weight because god knows i'm just going
to eat and drink all the time when i'm
back so yeah i know you should like
weigh yourself before just let's like as
an experiment i don't want to know i
don't should i i want to know [ __ ] it's
gonna be like christmas holidays all
over again exactly
holidays like
i don't know like do you guys gain
weight during the christmas holidays of
course yeah i can't wait generally
i breathe near mcdonald's and i gain
gameway
yeah but um hopefully you guys make it
back all right i mean i'm sure i'll be
all right because like i hope so yeah i
hope so i'm gonna the first thing i'm
gonna do is go to a [ __ ] nandos i'm
not even joking like before before i hug
my mum before say hello foresee with
family get myself to a nando's like mom
hold on hold on i'm gonna go to greg's
get a vegan sausage roll peacock vegan
and uh at a tesco meal deal perhaps too
maybe oh wow smalling yourself
[Music]
no don't think i will don't think i will
i think i'll get whatever the [ __ ] i
want and then i'll cry because i'll i'll
cry when i have to when i realize that
there's no good food options i think i
think i'm gonna miss japan a lot more
than i think i will yeah i think so
like you guys yeah i reckon like you
guys will obviously you know have that
like great rush of like yeah i'm back
home i'm seeing my family i'm seeing my
mates but then you'll realize like man
there's just so much [ __ ] to do in japan
i'm looking forward to ordering a coffee
in english that's very exciting
very exciting time i i i am like looking
forward to going to a tesco's which is
our combines and uh also doing that in
english and having having the clerk
respond to me and having an english
conversation with another person just
just
like have it
like
being asked if i want a plastic bag
another fukudo yeah that'd be nice
that'd be nice oh yeah they'll be like
drawing about like oh you don't like
this
no i'm good oh suica
yeah i i gotta realize i haven't paid
with my card in so long in the uk you
just tap it yeah so i'm excited for that
i'll be fine oh yeah that's the thing
tap and go oh my god well i actually
can't do that straight away because all
my products all my cards are expired
[ __ ] all my uk cards are expired
um yeah i'm i'm lucky i have a bit of uk
cash on me because i've only got my
japanese card on me right now but it's
not he's a visa or mastercard which is
just the two companies that everybody
like everyone else uses it's like jcb or
something like that which i've only ever
heard in japan yeah that's only in japan
yeah um and i don't think anywhere else
yeah is that i thought it was japan's
central bank i thought
i don't know it's japan's something so
it doesn't work outside japan it's all
nonsense
well hopefully i mean i mean luckily i
guess the good thing is that like yeah
since it will be six weeks we're gonna
have a lot to talk about next step yeah
yeah uh hopefully if uh you'll know
everything's gone smoothly if trash
taste is uninterrupted yeah yeah yeah
exactly if one of us gets stuck or for
for some reason uh yeah rip trash tastes
good how's it gonna feel for you joey
not being in not having a trash case
record every week i mean september i
mean september is just going to be a
very like slow month for me i guess it's
going to be weird waking up on a tuesday
morning being like wait i don't i don't
have to go to the office it's not a work
day today what the [ __ ] true yeah but um
i think like for me because i'm not
going to go back to australia because i
don't want to go through that whole
process um but i am going to go see my
family in japan
so that's going to be nice to finally
catch up with them because they're all
uh vaccine now [ __ ] yeah so uh yeah it's
gonna be nice to just like live like how
i used to live like three years ago when
everything was a lot more simple and i
could just i'm i'm i'm waiting for the
day until they actually let tourists in
here oh dude yeah i think that's why i
want to go back now because i'm like i
don't see it happening anytime soon
if i go now i'm fine if it takes another
two years yeah definitely i i think it's
gonna take two years no but if it does
it does it could it could i don't know
how long it's going to take yeah yeah
yeah yeah but uh but anyway i guess
we'll wrap it up we'll wrap it up here
hey look at all these patrons though
they're pretty cool
hey guys if you want to support us on
patreon and support the show then make
sure to go to patreon patreon.comtaste
also follow us on twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our face listen to us on spotify but uh
yeah guys have a good day gross now
hearing that fly story sorry i feel
disgusting and i feel sick too i'm
surprised i made it for this episode
yeah something to say it like i
literally think back and i'm just
i i i needed to tell someone because uh
no no i'm still scared it's like it was
like a [ __ ] horror story
no i was just gonna say like hope you
guys have a good trip i hope so too yeah
see you guys in six weeks and we'll see
you guys next week next week yeah
nothing has changed nothing has changed
if we did our job right yes and we get
back okay and uh and uh we are in the
country okay and yeah the problem
happens which are touch words yeah i
think it's [ __ ] slam that would
[ __ ] slam
all right guys have a good one
[Music]
you